to capture your oh wait hold on oh oh oh don't say anything important okay i said everything important just now i'm sorry can you repeat your social security number that's just for you okay i bet everybody can read lips right yeah yeah true true i'll sound it out okay
Wow.
I can't believe it has those numbers in there.
That's crazy.
And five more.
Oh my God.
Wow.
That's my social security number.
All right.
Anybody who wants a piece of made mint precious money.
Yep.
What do you even get out of having someone's social security number?
Identity.
fraud.
They could become me!
Yeah, we're all mint.
We're all mint-o.
Oh yeah, you guys could open a credit card.
Yeah, everyone open a credit card, but like take care of it really well and increase mint's credit score.
I'll get like updates, they'll be like you're overdue on a payment and I'll just make a community post being like hey whoever didn't pay your bill get to yeah
okay that's actually a great idea that's not like fraud is it if like it feels too good to be fraud if that's fraud then I don't want to be right exactly I don't want to be yeah like having your viewers open uh uh cards in your name so that they can increase your credit score.
There was one time I was watching Matara's stream.
This was like a year ago or something.
And she was like seriously proposing some sort of like...
I don't remember.
It was like some sort of money scheme.
And she was just like, I'm going to do this.
And everyone in her chat was like, you can't do that.
You're going to go to jail.
I think she should have done it.
I think it's okay.
If you have a pure heart, then it shouldn't matter if you commit a crime.
It was so funny.
I was watching it.
And just everyone.
Yeah, it was like some sort of pyramid scheme or something.
I wish he was legitimately proposing it.
It was so funny.
It was crazy.
What the hell?
Or a stocks thing.
Yeah.
I don't know.
She's so silly.
Matara Khan.
No.
Matara fraud.
Let's create a pyramid scheme together, Barry.
Okay.
What do you want the main thing to be?
We should...
Should we sell something or should we like...
Yeah.
Maybe we should...
Maybe we should sell something or maybe we should...
I kind of think it would be honest.
if we like locked like a hundred bug bros and a hundred wisps in like a room and just and like you know like had a death game or something.
Oh yeah that's not a pyramid scheme but it's still like a scheme.
That is a scheme yeah.
I was thinking I was thinking we create a business where you like sell smiles and then you know you you then recruit more people to smell sell smiles.
and then they should do it do it like you know um like in times square like when you take a picture with a mascot they like hound you to pay them they should yeah yeah yeah yeah so you tell you like you go up to a person you tell a joke and they laugh and you like harass them for five bucks yeah you're like hello and then and then you're like okay well if you don't want to pay me five bucks uh then you have to go to another person and make them smile yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh there's so many smiles in my chat right now yeah everyone's so everyone's smiling you guys stop i accidentally said smell now they're making fun of you it's okay i think you're cute when you're made fun of that's messed up
oh wait wrong toggle wait what did you toggle what What did you do?
The knife.
I took out the knife.
Oh.
Me too.
You too?
Oh my god.
What would you do if you saw two girls staring at you with a knife?
Pay up.
You smiled.
You saw our smiles.
Yeah.
Pay up.
Except my...
Wait, we should...
Maybe we should introduce ourselves.
Oh yeah, actually, I don't even think we said hello!
Oh, you're right!
Okay!
Hi everybody!
Hello!
Oopsie!
Oopsie, we're just chatting the entire time.
I know!
My tongue is so stupid.
Okay, introduce yourself.
Okay, hello, my name is Gregory the Pocket Bug.
And I'm here today.
No, Gregory, you're the lone surviving Pocket Bug.
If you don't understand, please go watch Nimmy's birthday maize stream.
Yeah.
Where Mint and Phoebe did their best.
What do you mean?
out it was perfect did their best yeah did their best yeah um yeah i i'm very oh my god sorry you could hear stuff in the background but i'm very and i'm a bug i'm a ladybug and i'm here today with The looks at hand to scribbled writing.
Mernt?
Mernt.
Introduce yourself, Mernt.
I'm Mernt.
I sell smiles.
I was recruited two years ago.
I'm ranked...
Wow.
I'm ranked 50,072.
Yeah.
Um.
Wow, you're high enough to like, when you die, you're definitely going to get a planet.
Oh yeah.
I forgot to say, our pyramid scheme works like Scientology.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hell yeah.
So you'll become astral projected when you sell enough smiles.
And everybody below you also sells enough smiles.
yeah yeah and see you guys definitely want to sell some smiles now right this is i feel like this is just smiling friends oh my god wait i've never watched that show but i learned okay have you heard about the what is it like awesome autistic gamer 777 a cool autistic gamer i forgot the about that.
I don't, I've never watched Smiling Friends before, but I learned about that the other day.
It's so funny.
I'm just gonna start doing that with you where I'm just gonna like, I'm just gonna have clips of you on my stream and I'm just gonna like pretend it's a collab where it's like you're like playing India and Jones and I'm just like, wow, that was a nice one,
Mint.
And you like time it where I'm like, oh, thanks.
And then you'll be like, hi.
You just watched it awesome.
You just watched the cool bug gamer.
774.
Thank you.
I know.
I've been kind of obsessed with that concept.
It's so funny.
He's so awesome, actually.
Because he's been getting better at like animate.
People think it's like a psyop by one of the creators.
No, it has to be.
Because there's like, he's now in the show.
And...
Like, it's kind of insane.
Like, kids, but I don't know.
They've been doing it for, like, years.
So it's crazy.
It's, like, the longest running joke ever.
It's so silly.
It's so crazy, man.
The fact that it's, like, even somewhat believable that one of the creators can be behind it is, like, insane to me.
Have you watched Smiling Friend?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Is it good?
It's very, it's very fun.
There's like stuff that there's stuff that I repeat from that show all the time.
It's so bad.
Okay, I'm gonna watch it now Yeah, it's so it like gets into your brain like a little worm You're gonna you're gonna start saying you're gonna start repeating stuff from that show my real person Oshi is also in that Show as a voice actor Rocco's in the show not Rocco If he were in it,
that would make sense too.
No, it's this guy named Mike Staclossa.
He's from a YouTube channel called Red Letter Media.
And he is my Oshie.
Who was he in the show?
I don't remember the guy's name.
He wants to die.
He wants to die?
Yeah.
I feel like that could probably be a lot of characters in the show, to be honest.
Oh, he was in the pilot.
Oh, oh, he's Desmond.
That's my Oshi.
Wait, that's awesome.
What the hell?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
He's a really silly guy.
Like, actually, he's so silly.
It's really cool because they have, like, a lot of new grounds people, like, and a lot of old internet references.
Like they referenced or they got the Hello handsome That like really scary old YouTube video With the mannequin Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Yeah yeah yeah they got that guy to like be on the show David Firth or something Right?
Oh wow Yeah it's like It's very cool to see It's like cool to see like the Newgrounds People like grow up And when they have their own show It's still like kind of almost It's like the same brand of humor kind of and it's like but it's on tv and you're like wow they made it i know yeah i they uh the adult swim youtube had like a i don't know if they still have it but they had like a 24 7 like just playing the episodes live stream and i i was watching i was watching a small bit of it but even just the small bit that i was watching i was like oh my gosh it's like one of those types of shows where they combine a bunch of different mediums where it's just like 3D characters.
Kind of very like Gumball.
Gumball-ish.
Yeah!
They have like Claymation.
They have like a PlayStation character in one of the episodes where he's like all polygonal.
It's crazy.
It's so good.
It's so cool.
I love stuff like that.
Yeah.
Cool.
I watch Smiling Friends, everybody.
Hey, hello there.
Woo!
Yeah, and but speaking of Newgrounds, this game is very Newgrounds coded, I feel.
We're here!
We're back with Battle Block, Berry Block Theater.
We're back with Meat and Block Kingdom.
Yeah!
What?
You know, after our collab, I went to Newgrounds and I was like, I wonder if any of those games are still there.
But now you need an account!
Oh, really?
Okay.
To look at like...
Oh, that is also dead, no?
Oh.
Oh, I don't know what they did with all the games, right?
Hmm.
Did they, did they like adapt all the games?
I have no idea.
I haven't been since...
forever so i have no idea yeah there's also flashpoint there where they save like a bunch of old flash games and like uh animations that you can use too yeah yeah yeah minto's not able to play meat and kingdom anymore i just wanted to relive my nostalgia i was like oh i'll go see what they're if they're there walking along i'm going doing my little side quests the elves.
Oh, no.
The controller just...
Wait, your controller is acting up.
What the heck?
No, it's okay.
It disconnected because we're inactive.
Oh, okay, okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
But yeah, so...
I was gonna go see.
And then, um...
Yeah, you need an account.
And I was like, I don't think I'm gonna make a new crowds account.
So...
You don't want to start...
You don't want to start uploading.
uploading content to Newgrounds.
You should- Wait, can you- I wonder if you could stream on Newgrounds.
Wait, you could probably- Maybe, but you could definitely upload videos at least, right?
Wait, I would love to see you on Newgrounds.
Wait, I have a game.
And- What, really?
Yeah, you're in it, remember?
Oh, oh!
I thought we met a different genre.
I was like, what are you doing?
I mean, I mean, I could make one.
Mint and...
Just like one of those visual novel, novel-like creator things.
And then I'll do all the art and the voice acting.
Oh my god, wait.
Like you should draw all the art yourself.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, we'll meet.
up at mint and bug kingdom yeah mint and phantom kingdom yeah mint and bug kingdom mint and miss mint and whisk and bug kingdom mint and freak can't kingdom yeah would you want to be the pro tag what does that entail
mint answer the question.
Let's play Battle Block Theater.
Yeah, we're playing, of course, we have to play Meat and Block Kingdom.
What am I talking about?
Yeah, sorry, Meat and Block Kingdom.
Yeah, Meat and Block Kingdom.
Wait, where is the visual novel of this game then?
Wish.
All right, let's start.
Yeah!
Wait, how do I...
Oh, there we go.
I forgot which one I was.
You forgot I was the triangle head.
Yeah, we're both cats, I think, right?
Yeah, we're little cats.
Ah!
I'm bullying you.
Why?
It's silly!
It is silly!
Oh, no!
Oh, wait, where'd she go?
You pushed me into the other room.
What's wrong with you?
Oh, the game...
You must know.
James getting a little freaky.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Fight back, Berrybug!
Fight back!
I'm trying!
You're locking me in a sun move!
Oh!
You pushed me back into the door!
Come on, Berry!
What?
Lock it!
Lock it, Berry!
What?
This is so mean!
Stop the violence!
Oh my gosh, my game is like lagging like crazy.
Oh no, oh shit.
Should you host?
I don't know.
No, I think it's okay.
Okay, okay.
Probably.
Oh gosh.
Are you guys seeing this chat?
I chat.
Are you seeing this chat?
Yeah.
Are you seeing this?
Stop!
Yeah, there you go.
Okay, you got me.
Wait, I think we already did this.
I think we're on four, right?
Yeah, I think we're on four out of eight, right?
I was just trying to run away.
out oh we go back this is what you've done to me oh how do i throw my things uh uh okay get closer to me oh oh yeah you can do that wait how do i do it oh oh it's a it's circle i don't know which uh oh there you go ah wait i don't want this how do i change i don't remember oh gosh hold on sorry
I don't remember how to change my thing.
Oh, you need to go to player setup.
You need to go to settings.
Oh, okay, there it is.
Um, I don't know.
I, I, maybe the fireball.
Mm-hmm.
Why?
Wait, what the heck?
You made me frown.
Oh, here we go.
Let's go in.
We got a speed run a little bit, don't we?
Oh, yeah.
I have something to do later tonight.
So we got a speed run.
We'll show you guys.
guys what it's like this is a pro but then welcome to games done quick where we do games quick yeah this is a speed run of battle block oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah hey what the hell oh you kill me i didn't who did that oh more more more battle blocks oh you can carry them yeah i think I think that's what you're supposed to do.
Wait, are we locked?
Wait, how did you carry it?
Uh, with this, oh, okay, never mind.
We're not.
Oh!
Ow!
I died!
Oh, I think we need to stack them.
We need to stack them.
Yeah, yeah.
How did I die?
How?
What the heck?
How will this affect our time?
Oh, help me out!
Do you remember how to do that?
Wait, why are you crossing your arms?
Don't explode on me.
Oh, it's that button.
Oh, there you go.
No, no, keep doing it.
Keep doing it.
Wait, why?
What's happening?
There we go.
My god!
Why are you keep dying?
I don't know, why do I keep dying?
Why do you save me?
Okay, okay.
I'll help you.
Oh, oops.
Don't look there.
Don't look now, but...
Don't look that way.
What the heck?
How do we do that?
Oh, we have to go from above.
I think.
I don't think we're beating the speed run for this.
There you go.
Good job.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I don't know what that...
Oh!
Okay, these developers might be a little bit smart.
Oh, oh, oh!
Kill him!
I killed him!
You're a killer.
You're a...
This is the...
Why do I keep dying?
I don't touch his head.
Oh, dude!
Wait!
Ah!
Kill him!
Oh, good job.
Wait, oh no!
Oh, wait, do we need...
Okay, I got it.
It's okay.
Yeah, good enough.
Okay, let's go.
There you go.
Look at us working together.
Oh, isn't it nice?
Yeah!
Look at us!
Okay, now...
Oh!
Wait, which way are we going?
I don't know.
Where are we going?
In here!
Go!
Oh!
Get in there!
Oh, I can't!
I can't!
Stop!
You're right.
Um...
Then what do we do?
And we think we go up.
Oops.
Oh, there's a teleporting thing somewhere.
Oh, wait.
Is this not a...
Oh, nope.
There's gotta be a secret here.
Ah!
What are you laughing at?
Ah, how cute you are!
I'm looking.
I'm...
Ah!
Observing.
Hold on.
Wait.
How do I go back down?
We have to like, yeah, we have to like go down here.
Ow!
But I don't know how to, how do you do that?
Oh, no, I don't know.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What are we doing?
I don't know.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
This is really, this is really shaving off, shaving on a lot of time.
Yeah.
This is really adding a lot of time to our speed run.
I thought I could do it.
I thought I could, I could tank it.
I should, I could take it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, we definitely do.
We have to, we have to go up.
How'd you do that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
With my brain.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
This is fine.
Okay.
And then boom.
And then, oh, whoa.
Is that it?
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Okay, now we're good.
Now, okay.
I'm fine.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
Okay, okay, we're back.
We're back.
We're back to her.
I forgot that that was a thing.
Just like seeing you die in like a thousand different ways.
Wait, I don't...
Oh, there's another gemmy!
Yeah, yeah, get that.
Get that.
Oh, how do I?
I will get it.
I'm getting it.
Okay.
Yeah, wait, wait, there's more!
Is there another one?
Okay.
Why can't I jump?
What's wrong with me?
I'm leaving this tree.
It is weird.
We have to get used to the game again, guys.
It's been a while, okay?
Oh my God, we just missed two!
We've been!
Oh, no way.
It's because we were too busy speed running, obviously.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I think I need to throw you.
I think I need to throw you.
Oh, okay, okay.
Welcome back.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Go, go, go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
What was that for?
Okay, I'll
let you...
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, how do I do it again?
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, it ain't so funny now, is it?
to say a curse word right now dude oh i deserve that
dude i actually though um i recently saw this uh really funny thing online i don't know if you i don't know if you saw it but um oops well you might have seen it because you're on like sick talk right yeah yeah but so there there's like this girl um oh my god and she says hawk toa
Oh my gosh, wait, I've never heard of this before.
It sounds like so funny.
Yeah.
What is...
Because she like...
She goes...
She goes Hakua.
Okay.
And you're never gonna guess this, but she...
She started a coin.
Oh god, I'm a fighter too.
Oh my goodness, great man.
Okay.
And I just wanted to say, I used your social security number.
the beginning of strength to put all your savings into the Hawk to a coin.
No freaking way.
I want to just say that you will become a millionaire.
The Hawk to a coin is in high demand.
Yeah, exactly.
How do I... Oh, what?
Do I... Oh, I put this here?
Oh, no, I remove it.
Yeah.
You're right.
So I think you'll be seeing a lot of...
of good fortune come your way soon oh okay yeah oh oh oh how did i do that how did you do that i think i'm a gamer i think so what the hell oh oh oh wait but the miss miss miss miss miss yeah why'd you kill me i didn't you didn't let me get off oh i now i'm stuck wait i'm stuck I'm getting sandwiched.
I'm literally getting sandwiched right now.
Wait, but we didn't get the...
We didn't get the yarn.
Is that okay?
Oh, we didn't get the yarn.
You're right.
Where the fuck was the yarn?
I saw it, but I didn't know how to get to it.
Oh.
Oh, whatever.
You want to go back?
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, my God.
this talk to her well i don't know she she went on a twitter space and she was like all right i'm about to head out y'all and that's why i'm gonna go to bed we're like warping into each other
isn't that crazy that's like literally the last we've ever heard of her it's kind of my favorite clip though because of how much she sounds like bart simpson she's just like all right i'm gonna
I thought she sounded really like sandy cheeks Because I had never heard her before Oh, yeah, me neither before that Yeah, and then you hear her and she's like Oh my god, and you're like, oh my god She sounds like that That's crazy She should become a V-Tuber I would love to hear her like I don't know about that I would love to hear her voice And oh,
oh, wait, we messed up No, we messed up Wait, I can grab it, I can grab it Okay, I can't grab it I can't grab it Oh, shh Oh my god, the cat's here!
Yeah, get him, get him!
Get him!
Okay.
Get him.
Wait, I'm trying to go through, but it won't let me.
Wait.
Okay, you run and then I run.
What?
No, I think it's doomed.
Oh no, we messed up!
Guys!
We messed up.
This is really gonna mess up our time.
Why does the frog do anything?
Push me?
What the heck?
Stop.
Whoa.
Mid, mid, mid.
You died again to your own frog.
Okay, now we're good.
We died.
Oh wait, I can do this.
Flappy bird.
Okay.
I should wait wait wait oh you have to get up.
Oh you have to go through.
Yeah you have to go.
Wait.
Alright means.
Easy?
First draw.
Oh damn it.
Wait.
Wait how am I supposed to get up here?
With the wings.
Wait but I have to be so fast.
Maybe?
Ah girl.
Oh.
are we dead ass right what the what wait where oh i did it oh no oh no don't come this way oh my god what happened um you try go up there okay okay okay okay okay
now i'm gonna die do the checkpoint okay come on do the check to bury Barry, do the check for it.
Oh my god, I can't...
Wait, but what if...
If you cheat in the game, you only cheat yourself.
Barry, Barry.
Barry.
I got the check for it, I got the check for it, you're fine.
Oh.
Oh, you made it!
And I still have my wings.
No, ah!
What the hell?
Me?
Police?
Oh, me?
What do you mean?
I can...
Oh,
they're disappearing.
That's not what I said.
Oh, I can...
Wait, what?
What are we doing?
We were just painting stuff in a very different light.
What's happening?
Wait, what's going on?
What's going on?
I don't know.
I think we're fine.
What are you worried about?
No, nothing.
Oh, okay.
And we're fine.
No, nothing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait, what are we doing?
I think we need...
Oh, there's a yard!
Oh, wait, the hat is right there by the yard!
Oh, how do we...
How do you...
How do we...
Oh, we have to probably take the rocks from here.
Yeah, I think so.
And put them in here.
Okay, good job.
I'll go get one.
Wait, okay, there we go.
How did you throw it?
ouch i died uh b
oh you made it here i'll try and get another one wait i didn't mean to do that oh we're almost out of time barry
it's okay it's okay i'm sorry guys my home address is one two three one two three smile street you guys can you guys can fucking talk to me wherever
Oh my god
I'm coming over Okay okay Are you bringing PT?
Oh yeah Yeah we'll play PT together Go Cause you're the only You're the You're the Only one in existence To have the 40 41 one-carat gold PT copy of Kojima's PT.
Are you okay?
I'm going insane.
I'm trying to grab this thing, but I can't.
Just like the complete silence.
I'm like, dude, I'm never doing a bit, I guess.
I don't need the collab, man.
Wait, come back here, come back here.
Okay, get out, go grab that thing up above my head.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, god damn it.
Thank you.
Okay, move.
Move.
Okay, we're fine now.
Okay.
Also, thank you for the raid, Lumi.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Get it!
I'm trying!
Oops!
I deserve that.
Ah!
What do we do?
Okay.
There's also, I think maybe, I don't know actually.
Maybe...
Oh, oh, wait!
Leap, wait.
Oh, oh.
Jump on my head!
Jump, jump!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Okay.
Oh, I think you need to throw me, or I throw you.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Up there.
Nice.
We're here.
Thank you.
Oh, ha!
Whoa!
Wow!
Why I just thought, why are you kicking me while I'm down?
That's not very...
sportsmanship of you.
Wait, you're the one who's making everything terrible.
I'm making it terrible.
Oh my god.
Is that how you do it?
What is that?
I don't know, actually, what we're supposed to do here.
Oops.
I didn't get...
I can't.
Oh, we need two of them.
Yeah, I know.
That's why I was trying to get the other.
Wait, where does it go?
It goes to...
Wait, hold on.
I want to see...
Is this anything?
Like up here?
Yeah!
How many times have I died by Boulder?
Oh shit, wait!
Oh, I think it went back to the beginning.
I think so, I think so.
Oh my god, I'm gonna pass out, dude.
Throw!
Damn it.
Yo!
Okay, it's a little heavier than I thought it would be.
Yea, yeah, yeah, you got it.
Okay, move.
Throw!
Okay.
Grab it.
Grab it!
Wait, wait.
I thought you were gonna cry.
What?
Okay, okay, okay, I'll see you.
I'll see you here.
Okay.
And then I grab it and I throw it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Yay!
Oh, sorry I threw out a frog again.
You're like puking frogs.
What is this thing?
I know.
Oh!
Oh, we can ride it?
We can ride him.
Oh, you can go on spikes!
Oh!
Wait, this is huge!
Ah!
Alright guys!
Oops!
There are you!
Nice aim!
Thanks!
Is pixel perfect?
Oops.
What?
It's gracious!
Oh,
dude, they come to you when you cry for help.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, you can't jump though.
Yeah, you have to like...
Wait, how do they...
Oh, I think.
Just like that.
Did we miss anything?
I feel like we definitely did.
I'm gonna go back up.
Okay.
You think so?
Oh, we did miss something.
We did miss something at the end.
I'm getting sandwiched!
I got it!
Good job!
I got it.
I'm just down here.
Oh, you're getting sandwiched.
Let me alone.
Ah!
You good?
Yeah, I'm fine.
Kill that guy.
I'm killing him.
Oh, and yourself.
Stop!
I'm not trying, dude.
Go away!
Okay!
She hates me, you guys.
It's sweet.
You got...
Oh, what?
Wait, what are we supposed to do here?
How are we supposed to get the...
The...
The thingy?
I don't know.
Also up here.
Okay.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No.
Okay, jump off of me.
Okay.
Yeah, we got all of them!
Yeah, we didn't get the yarn.
Yeah, try and get the yarn.
How are you supposed to get the yarn, though?
Oh my god!
Oh, oh, oh!
You're so close!
Oops.
Oh!
Okay, I think you boosted me.
Yeah!
Oh, guys, I don't think we're making the speedrun record.
What are you talking about?
They're literally writing our names up right now.
Oh, true, true, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I forgot there's, like, glasses and stuff in this.
Well, yeah, we'll shave off a lot of time with our boss time because we'll be so good at the bosses.
Yeah, exactly.
If there are bosses.
Yeah.
Okay, come, come, come.
Yeah, yeah.
Please, please don't.
Don't.
Thank you.
I always trusted you.
I never, I never, I never doubted you for a second.
Never doubt me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is there a secret?
There's gotta be.
Oh, oops.
Uh-oh, I don't have any wings anymore.
Ah.
Uh-oh.
Oh, there's another...
What are these?
You probably...
I mean, you need to press the switch at the bottom to...
Oh, that's what those do.
Okay, here.
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh, here.
Here.
Uh.
Oh, here.
Oh, sorry.
Here.
Okay.
And then, oh.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm drinking water.
I'm no longer dying.
You can get up here on your own, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Alright, don't die.
Actually, I think I'm...
Okay, now go through.
Keep going.
Just go.
Fly!
I'm going.
Spread your wings and fly!
Mary, go home!
Okay, now I'm gonna kill myself.
Oops.
Okay.
Kill yourself.
I can't do that actually.
I'm too good at living.
Oh my god, no way.
Oh, okay.
So one time.
I think we...
just get the wings i'm stupid there's there's also a self-destruction oh you can get the wings
hold we're cool everything oops
i got this oh i'm upset i'm downstairs now what did i respond oh you got this get the yard i'm getting it i'm getting it Nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh.
Okay, that's where that goes.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh my god, Miss!
That's not me!
It's you!
Okay, now what?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, and this unlocks the other part.
We're over here now.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Wow, wow,
wow.
Your phone notification is a gem collect noise?
What the heck?
Someone said that.
Wow.
Yeah, someone in my chat.
How is your phone notification noise still this?
They're invested into this game.
Yeah, you're an OG battle blocker.
Good job.
Gem, gem, gem, gem, gem.
Okay, this way?
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna launch you.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna launch you.
Okay, again.
Okay, I'm gonna launch you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's try the other side.
Let's try.
Okay.
I'm gonna launch you.
Okay, let's try.
Let's go back to the main plan.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, and shit.
Okay, you're good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oops.
I think we go back now, maybe?
Oh, yeah, probably do.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
The other side is open.
All right.
Hoi.
Oh, we're so back.
Okay.
We are so- Why did you do that?
Why is this- Well, why- that's so suspicious, isn't it?
Oh, you're right.
I don't see anything there, though.
Yeah, maybe not.
Thank you.
This is really dangerous.
Okay, don't worry.
And there's a...
There's a little guy... there's a gemmy.
I'm gonna launch you.
Okay, launch me.
I told you I don't want to get launched anymore.
I have pixel perfect aim.
I don't think you see it.
I die by grenade, you die by...
I'm scared.
Okay, I got rid of him, though.
Oh, good job, good job.
Yeah, we're good.
Oh, okay.
Let me out.
You know, we're playing a team game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right, right, right.
This is a team game.
This is not...
This is co-op, if you guys can believe it.
Oh!
Oh, what the heck?
What the?
Kill him!
Oh.
Kill!
Kill, kill, kill!
Um, I'm gonna launch you.
No, I'm gonna launch you.
Oh.
No.
I'm gonna launch you.
Okay, launch me.
See?
Oh my god, it worked!
Oh, and then you...
Drop it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, yeah.
Come on.
Thank you.
Wait, is this the way we go?
I guess so.
How do we get through, though?
How do we...
I don't think we go this way.
Uh...
But then how do we get the...
I think down here, down here, maybe?
Hold on.
Hold on, I have an idea.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I don't want you.
Don't launch you.
I don't think that's gonna work.
Never mind.
It worked.
My plan failed.
Oh, wait.
Was this open before?
No, it wasn't.
Ah!
You have to distract him!
Okay, I have to distract him!
You're just so tasty!
Oh, wait, what is this?
Oh, and then, and then...
We call him.
Oh, they come over!
Help!
Wait, we can use them to get over to here.
Through here.
True, true, true, true.
Okay.
Oh, wait, but the...
Hold on.
There's also a yarn.
Yeah, we gotta get the yarn.
Wait.
No, we can't.
Uh, what's...
Where's the...
Oh, I see where the teleport is.
Where?
It's right...
Oh, okay, hold on.
Oh, it was a secret!
Yeah, it was a secret.
Oh.
We got this, guys.
We got this.
Okay, you go get it.
I'll...
I'll stay near the spot.
Okay.
Oh, wait, no.
Maybe you need my help, though.
No, I don't think so.
I think you need me.
Oh, I do need you.
Oh, say that again.
I can't fly this plane without by myself.
Okay.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, you got this.
There you go.
Okay.
All right.
Now we can leave.
Now we can go.
Oops.
Indeed.
Okay.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Wait me.
No, I'm coming!
Please!
Don't leave me behind!
Ah.
Alright.
Yay!
Oh my god, everything.
Yippee!
I survived rabies!
Yeah, we all survived rabies.
Wait, I want to go to the store.
Yeah, me too.
Unless you want to go to the store, maybe.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Let's go.
Oh, oh.
Wait, sorry?
Wrong button, wrong button.
I have 38 jemmies.
Which one is the...
Oh!
10?
Yeah.
I want to use a square.
I want to go into the square.
Square.
Be there, and she's square.
TV!
Wow!
Okay.
Oh, that's it.
That's all I have.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to.
Okay, okay.
Angory.
Okay.
That's good if you didn't survive rabies.
That's like a chupacabra.
That's a regular iguana.
No, that's a porcupine, isn't it?
I don't know.
Wait, how much are these?
Five?
Oh, I have four.
What do you have?
Oh, I have five.
Did you just get a golf ball?
Yeah, what is that?
Wait, hold on.
What the hell?
You're playing games.
Wait, that's it.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, that's it.
It's only... It's nothing.
I can't even interact with it.
Oh, yes, I can!
It's just a bouncy ball.
I just got a bouncy ball.
Yeah, but we can play catch with it.
Okay, catch.
Oh.
All right, let's go.
No, I don't know if I can detonate it.
I think it's just...
Oh my god.
Very bug.
You're really dragging down the morale.
No, my morale is at an all-time high.
Yay!
Shall we find some sparkly gems?
Sparkly gems.
All right.
Oh!
Oh, there's a secret!
We must follow the secret.
Do we follow this guy?
I think so.
It seems like we do, right?
He's like going up?
Or wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, no, I think you're right there.
Oh.
Oh, wait, hold on.
You go, and then I'll go.
Okay.
There you go.
This just seems like the way to progress.
Oh, yeah, I think.
So.
Oh, oh.
Wait, it's supposed to be down here?
Oh!
Keeping lucky.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you for the raid on Twitch.
Thank you for the raid!
I'm gonna die.
Oh, wait, we need the boulder here.
To block it.
Right?
Oh, oh, no.
Wait.
Wait, should we restart?
How do we...
Oh, is that the restart?
If you... if we both do the left one?
Or... Is that it?
I don't know what this is.
I don't know what this is either.
What is that?
Oh!
Wait, I have a... Oh, I have an option.
Maybe that's just...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I did.
All right, all right, all right.
I won't just throw it down.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We know now.
Yeah.
Oops.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
My bad.
Okay.
I got it.
Oh, why did I not mess?
Oh, you got it.
Okay.
I got it.
Ah.
Oh, she gamed.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Have your ticket ready.
Wait, is that it?
Uh.
Ah!
There it is!
That's it!
Oh there it is!
How do I get up here?
Oh my gosh, here we go.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Bye bye.
Oh shit.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
No, there's a gold.
There's a...
I gotta get the...
Yeah, how do I...
How do you...
There you go!
Oh, there you go.
Okay, okay.
Is that it?
No, there's more.
There's gotta be more.
Oh god.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Get it, get it, get it, get it, get it.
I got it!
Nice!
Yay!
We got all of it!
That was...
That was insanity.
Yeah, they're so fucking chaotic.
It's time too!
I'm gonna redo this.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess we do.
Ah, mean.
Alright.
Okay, ignore that guy.
Ignore him.
Yeah, ignore that guy.
Freak that guy, man.
Oh, wait, but this gemmy here.
Okay, I'll get it, and then I'll die.
Yeah, just...
Okay, die.
Okay, I die.
And then we can just move on.
Yeah, now we can keep going.
Okay.
Oh.
I thought there might be a secret up there, but...
There was not.
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
The thing is over there.
Oh, oh, you see, I see, I see.
Wait.
Is that good enough?
Can you get it with that?
Um...
No.
Well, I messed up.
Yeah, you can.
Yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Okay, okay, okay.
You can climb out there.
Oopsie.
Yeah, we're fine.
Alright, we'll just climb back here.
Yeah, whatever, whatever, man.
Okay, I'll press this.
Okay, go grab that and kill that guy.
Yeah.
Oh, hi.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, okay, nice.
Nice.
Okay.
Get this guy out of here.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
I'm so strong.
You are so strong.
I'm so brave.
I'm so strong.
We're doing it.
Oh, I didn't even notice that.
Okay, that's all the gems, I think.
Oh, yeah, it was.
Actually, this is the exit.
Was it?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, we're good, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
I think?
Right?
Yeah.
I mean, did you do your homework from last time and listen to the song that I recommended you?
Almost.
What was it again?
Uh, the, the, the, the FNAF song I recommended you.
Yes, I did.
How did you think about it?
I don't remember.
It was just so good that it shocked your system that you forgot it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't remember, actually.
Oh, shoot.
My name is Edwin, and I made the mimic.
Oh, keep going.
It was difficult to put the pieces together.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, maybe you time it better.
Very...
Okay, okay, okay.
There you go.
Is that good?
Or...
Yep.
Yeah.
We're fine.
Go, go!
Okay, we can't...
There's two of ones!
Okay.
Oh, let's see.
This looks like a whole lot of fun.
You...
What about...
You didn't like the...
My name is Jackie.
And I'm fucking backy.
I don't know why I don't remember this song.
Like, I do, but I don't.
You like actually blocked it from your number.
I think I did.
Wait, I think I need your help.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
It's like a fan.
Send me over!
Ah!
Yeah!
Okay, okay, stay there.
Okay, okay, wait, hold on.
I'm trying.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay.
You got this?
Oh!
Okay.
It's good now.
There we go.
I think you're good.
Maybe.
Is that it over there?
I think so.
Okay.
I killed him.
Oh.
Come on.
All right.
You're good.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
All right.
Chill.
Okay.
Wait, what is...
Oh, there's a...
The ball of yarn!
Where?
Down here?
Oh, I see it.
Over...
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, so you hold that and then you...
Okay, I go here.
Oh, okay, okay.
But what is this?
What is...
I don't know.
It's a death trap.
That's the way it is.
I think you have to...
Yeah, because staying on this makes it go up.
So I think you have to...
You have to get me to go up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And not die.
Okay, I'll let you handle this.
No, I think...
I need your help timing.
Oh!
Well, why do we need it?
How far?
Oh, I guess because it...
Why don't I just launch you?
Come here.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um, there you go.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, that way.
No, wrong way.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Right here is the way to do it.
Okay, come on.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Okay, let's time this.
Okay.
Oops.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Okay, I saw her.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I turn.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, hold on.
That was close though.
That was close.
Oh,
wait, wait.
Just stay up there.
You're so right!
How do I get up there?
Just kill yourself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I spawn down here again.
Okay.
What?
Oh, there's nothing else up here!
There's nothing!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god, the camera is...
Oh my god!
Why did it spawn me here?
Why did you spawn there?
Why did it spawn here too?
Oh my god.
I killed us both.
I took us both out.
Why does this exist?
Why why does it exist, like.
What the, what the?
What the?
What the what the?
Oh no,
no!
Oh damn it!
I lost the hat!
Oh, oh, oh...
Wait, hold on... You got the hat?
No, I didn't get it.
Wait, oh wait, it drowned!
The hat drowned?
No, stinking way.
What the heck?
No!
Stop the violence!
Oh, you are!
Yeah, we were so close.
It's okay.
I didn't like...
What is this?
Oh.
Okay.
This is a...
Let's go.
Oh wait, no.
Is he staying on that?
Yeah, he's staying on it.
Okay.
Maybe you should stay there.
I think I should launch you.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, yeah.
Like an actual, actually this time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Even the other times weren't actually...
Minto, Minto.
Thank you.
No!
I'm setting you on fire.
What the heck?
Trick or treat?
I only bring tricks.
Wait, I'll use my...
Wait, hold on.
Dang it!
I'll launch you.
Alright, okay, okay.
Is it a launching?
Actually, I don't know what this part is.
Oh, okay.
Go, go.
I can just stand on your head.
Oops.
Oh, come on.
Oh, maybe you can use that?
Yeah, like...
Oh, you could, yeah.
Oh, I can!
Yeah.
Handy.
Oh god, there's a...
Oh god.
Oops.
Okay.
Sorry, my bad.
Oh, ouch.
Oh.
Ah!
Okay.
How did I die?
I don't know.
Me and Boulders?
We don't really get a log, you guys.
You're like a lunatune skipper.
I think it's my controller.
But, who knows?
You're like wily coyote-ing yourself.
What is this?
Oh, we have to make it match.
There we go.
Oh, nah, okay, okay.
Oh, I thought I died.
Oh, I did.
Oh, no.
Wait, where have I...
Oh!
Fuck you.
Get out of here!
Yeah, kill him!
Kill him!
There you go.
Oh, that was close.
Yeah, turn it off.
Did you miss anything?
No, but I'm gonna go up here.
I feel like there's... Oh, maybe there's nothing.
Just kidding.
Maybe there's nothing.
Okay.
Whoa!
Be careful.
Oh, wait!
Up there!
Oh, oh, oh!
Wait, I think I have to go back through it.
I gotta go through it!
Wait, wait, what?
You think so?
I don't think so.
Oh, hello.
Actually, I can't.
Hi.
Oh, wait.
I'll set you both on fire.
Why me?
Why?
Okay, let me know what?
Yeah, jump up there.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
There you go.
There you go, yeah.
Oh, come on.
What is this?
Oh, there's gotta be something down there, maybe, no?
Right!
I don't know.
It's all so suspicious.
It is.
What, this way?
Yep.
Maybe?
Yep, there's a gemmy right there.
Yeah, yeah, there.
Okay, yeah, you're right, you're right.
Well, we didn't get all of them.
We didn't.
secret right no there can't i think it's here but i don't know why well that's where the ball was oh it was yeah okay just kidding me yeah i don't know maybe it's secret someplace else
fireball why are you trying to fireball me what's that game where you say all the like me yeah majorino yeah yeah yeah majorino fireball fireball fireball fireball fireball fireball
you're still gonna die oh time for boss oh damn oh my god this is this is domestic abuse no we We shared jellies.
We shared jellies at MGSCon.
Yeah, we did.
And you're abusing me.
You ate my pancakes.
You put your face on my boobies.
I was sad.
Oh, my God.
Oh, right, right.
This has a timeline.
Oh, okay.
No messing around here.
No messing around.
This way?
Yep.
Woo!
Distract him!
Okay, you distract him.
Okay, okay.
Uh-oh.
Oh, we're here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, wait, no, we gotta block now.
Okay.
Yeah!
Oh, I'm stuck in here.
Wait, where are you?
I'm gonna die.
Okay.
Okay, now we're good.
Okay, nice.
Oops.
What does this do?
Okay, that killed the cat.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I gotta press this.
Okay, okay.
And then I'll stand on this.
Yeah, and then I stand on this.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I gotta go on this.
Oh, okay.
And then you go on...
Oh, this?
And then you go this?
Okay.
Okay, and then...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
We are so smart.
Watch out because there's lasers?
S-M-E-R-T, smart.
S-S-S-S-S-S.
This is...
It's more.
That's the secret, isn't it?
The what?
Wait, where does that, what does that open?
I don't know.
Oh wait, we're supposed to drag this over here.
I see!
It opens up right here.
On the left.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, how are you supposed to do this?
Okay.
I'll keep blowing them up.
I don't think you blow them up.
I think we're supposed to use the...
We're supposed to put it on it.
Oh, I think so.
You're right.
Okay.
And then get on the next one.
Oh, no, no.
Sorry, I fireballed.
You fireballed.
Okay.
Well, let it grow.
Let it grow.
Okay.
Let it go.
There we go.
30 seconds.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Nice, nice.
Keep going.
Oh, we're fine.
Okay, okay, we're fine.
No, we're not fine.
Well, I'm okay.
I'll be okay.
I'm just, I'm continuing.
Yeah, just keep going.
Keep going.
Keep going without me.
I'm going.
I'm sandwiched.
Okay.
Wait, there's a ball there.
Can you, it's at the bottom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Okay, you got it.
Okay, we're going.
Okay.
Oh, that is not a good block to remove.
Wait.
How do you do this?
Oh, I'll stand on your head and then- Oh, there you go.
Yeah.
I'll go this way.
And then...
And then now you go down.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
And then...
And then now you can go...
Uh...
Nowhere.
No...
No, where.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Don't step on that.
Wait on that.
oh i don't know how you get over here i don't know either oh i think i know how maybe oh my god oh my god oh my god it's fine i'm here there's a there's a thing over there i got it nice nice you're so smart you're so smart okay okay i'll step on it oh thank you i'm going i'm going i got it i'll shoot okay nice okay okay sacrifice sacrifice yourself sacrifice sacrifice oh don't go up well we need at the same time.
Oh, we need to go up the other way, yeah.
Wait, there's another.
Oh, you got it.
I got it.
Oh, what the freak?
Oh, you're supposed to go there.
Um, I'm already here.
You're supposed to go there.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Now, now.
I feel like there's something down here, though.
Oh, a boulder?
Maybe?
We got a boulder, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Uh.
Yeah.
Up.
Okay.
going up?
Yeah.
What does that do?
Oh, I was supposed to throw it!
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
You got it, you got it, you got it.
Oh, oh, no, wait, hold on.
Okay.
Don't trust me.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, okay, now I'm gonna... Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Okay, okay.
It's gonna go up here.
Can you get to...
My, my trigger...
My... I don't... Don't trust me with the boulder.
Don't trust me.
My trigger is... It's out.
It's sabotaging.
Wait, wait, wait, you gotta go!
Wait, hold on.
Can you...
Yeah, yeah, nice, nice, nice!
Nice!
Okay!
You got it!
Okay, nice, nice!
Okay, we have to rush, we have to rush.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Just go.
Just go!
Go, go, just go!
I got it!
Oh my god!
Let's go!
That was awesome!
Oh, I don't even know what happened.
Take my dainty hand as I wish you back to a time long forgotten.
Long before the poop hit the fan here.
The year was 17, oh, 59-ish, whatever.
Self-made billionaire, cat fanatic, and theatrics officiato Perham Furbottom.
Perham Furbottom.
Ritsiest, most thrill-inducingest theater ever.
And you did.
And it was the talk of the town.
Titanic went there you are most assuredly square Wow seriously like what you weren't there what are you a nerd opening night was a thing to hear the square organized the grandest jaw-dropping ever seen there was explosions dancing girls dancing girls who exploded oh my god exotic animals who exploded incredible feats of magic and wonder with fantastic production values all around for days on end marveling at his breathtaking creation and packing handful of delicious buttery popcorn I like a popcorn but alas his logical contempt for intermissions ultimately caused his demise during the show Furbottom passed what having pooped himself to death on the way to the bathroom legend I was like did he get Abraham Lincoln but his little cheeks just gave out Furbottom left nothing behind why did he how did he poop himself more like poop bottom and of course his bloated course which was lovingly drifted out of the sea and immediately ravaged by sharks and that children is the legend of Purham
Furbottom bottom.
What a way to go.
Apparently delicious, a gentleman.
But the show must go on, right?
Right.
For thousands of years, Perham's hat passed from head to head.
Leader to leader.
And the theater still operates to this very day.
And what a piece of crap it's become.
I bet Perham is rolling over in his sharks right now.
I mean, everything's poorly run and the whole place stinks like pee in feet.
And with everyone involved walking a fine line between moodiness and furblown insanity.
It's only a matter of time before something truly horrifying happens.
disposition as you sink further into darkness yeah nobody likes a cry baby so so haddy is possessed by a ghost of we're glitched together i don't why are you saying it like that i forgot how many chapters are there naked oh yeah he took off all his clothes i know it looks like the next one is maybe the end like maybe there's five and then six and then maybe that's the end He is just like the people on Everest.
What are you saying?
You know, you start going crazy, you hallucinate, you take off your clothes, you walk off the edge.
Oh my god.
Hold on, I gotta blow my nose.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay, blow it into my ear.
Okay, let me find my tissues.
Okay, okay, I'll mute Discord so they don't get to hear.
Yeah, you guys don't get to hear.
Hold on.
Yeah, only I get to hear.
Come to Phantom Channel to hear me blow my nose.
I'm not muting.
No, no, no, no, no.
Mute on OBS.
Don't let them hear.
Yes!
Yes, yes!
My sinus is clear.
No, we're not.
It's not.
No, it's not.
I'm
so sorry you guys It's okay Actually I'm gonna mute for this one
Damn she really did mute
Um Thank you so much for the gifted The gifted memberships and everything Thank you guys Probably after collab I'll thank everyone if we have time But I really do appreciate it And everybody on Minced Channel, please give like a billion gifted memberships,
please.
Yeah.
Do it right now.
Hey, allergy!
Okay, I'm ready.
You just have an overload of ectoplasm.
That's exactly it!
I get it, I get it, it's okay.
We don't have to worry about time.
I launch you.
Okay.
Nice.
I wait patiently.
And then I...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, whatever.
We're fine.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Oh, why didn't you go up?
Do it again properly?
No!
Do it again properly.
Eagle.
Thank you.
I would never be so mean.
No.
You deserve that.
So I think you have to launch me.
There's like a teleporter over there.
Ah!
I thought... Oh, you're right.
I think you have to launch me.
Oops.
Uh-oh.
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Ah!
You got this?
Okay.
Launch.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Thank you.
Where is that?
Oh, what the?
I fell again.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Here you go.
Okay, thank you.
All right.
You just got to jump over them.
Just don't body block me.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
You know what you should play?
Oh shit.
What?
Sorry.
I have to recommend all the crazy games that you have to play while you can't leave in this collage.
lab what do you mean you have to play mario and what what is it called mario in the music box it's like an rpg maker game by um by uh somebody who really loves like mario rona mario who like mario from super mario okay and like i guess like the the person who like made the game is like really into Mario Arona.
Okay.
And like like it has like a ton of CGs and different ways for Mario to die.
It has like an anime opening in like intro when you launch the game in RPG Maker.
It's like crazy.
Oh.
Why aren't you going?
I can't get up there.
Oh, right, right, right.
But also there's a secret.
I was just so distracted by.
There is a secret.
I was so distracted by the Mario game.
I got so excited.
That's understandable.
Wait, did I drop that?
Do you drop that?
Or I don't know how.
Or maybe...
Oh, oh, is that how I come over?
For what?
But why is there...
There's, like, a guy here.
Yeah.
Where does he take us?
Oh, maybe you take it out.
Oh, yeah, I think you take it out.
I don't think you can take it out.
Yeah, you can.
Go to the left.
other left.
Right through there.
Yeah.
I can't.
Just get good.
Just get it.
I can't.
Just do it good.
You do it.
I can't.
Just do it good.
Hey.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh, you really can't.
Do it good.
Do it good, Mint.
No, you go over here.
Oh, wait.
Wait, how?
Wait.
But he's like running over...
Is he just stuck or is it actually...
No, I think it's a...
I don't know.
Oh, like to the...
I see, I see.
Oh my god, he's glitching out.
Okay.
Like, there's...
It's got to be...
It's over there.
But how do we get there?
It doesn't look like anything.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the memberships.
Thank you!
I don't know how.
Do you guys know how?
Hint!
Ablo, Ablo in Espanyol.
uh how do you say um uh oh my god he's going to see see see just see wait are you maybe maybe we bring something from over here yeah but how do we get this out of there i don't think we i think this is just for you to come back to the oh and to this side i think you're right yeah this is so Okay,
it's not that It doesn't have to do with the Wait Yeah, you've been the memberships But wait Maybe Maybe I mean with something down here No No No I don't know I don't think so Like that we both died at the same time
I guess I guess oh oh oh oh I don't know recommend roblox mint doesn't want to play roblox she's too mature and yeah I have good taste the brain is fully developed uh oh oh it goes through now yeah but the but the secret the secret you guys help us help us
I want the secret.
What's the secret?
Can you use your nerf gun?
Oh, wait!
You're right.
Maybe I can use my...
Is that anything?
It could be a little lower.
Oh, oh, dang it!
I almost had it!
Is that anything?
Oops.
Oh, my thing fell off.
Oh, yeah, I fell off.
Okay.
Can you get to that end one?
Oh, wait, hold on.
Uh...
Okay.
Oh!
Yeah, but I don't think I reach.
Yeah.
I need it.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah, come on.
Okay.
Die again.
Yeah, die again.
Just die.
What if it's not even here?
It has to be.
Wait, maybe?
Oh!
She was gaming!
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh!
The music is not the music.
We're used to.
Come on.
I think it's different between the stages.
Oh my god, this one's hard.
Oh my, this is, wait, this is actual parkour.
Oh my god, wait, I can't get anything.
Wait, this sucks.
This kind of sucks.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, oh you did it?
Oh, okay, nice.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's so many though.
Oh my god, I know.
Wait.
How the heck am I supposed to time?
This, uh...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I wanna get it, can I get the ball at least maybe?
How are you standing on ones that don't exist?
You just guess the timing.
I'm sorry, I messed up.
Three gems is still three gems.
How are we feeling?
We have to redo this one though, don't we?
We don't have to actually.
I think we, I feel like we got a majority of the, we were like close to the end.
You're right.
Okay.
Wait, actually, maybe we should redo it, because I don't know if it counts any of the gems that we do.
That's what I was wondering.
Yeah.
Okay, maybe we should redo that.
Go back and redo that.
Oh.
Really fantastic timing there.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, get him, get him, get him.
Feed him up.
And wait, that was me.
My bad.
Oh, X.
Okay.
wait oh no no okay now those start exploding or going up okay oh okay is this the secret there's got to be something over there yeah right yeah good job i'll be sniffing them out i'm like yeah you do oh i'm over here okay yeah wait i'm trapped there we go Uh-oh,
uh-oh.
Yeah, you gotta beat, yeah, okay, good job.
You got it, you got it.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, wait, what if I said no?
Wait, there's two of them.
I would try.
Wait, why are there two of them?
There's, there's two of them?
Wait, I'm actually stuck, I'm like, I can't...
I can't stop making love to this machine.
Wait.
Why did you...
Why should you say it like that?
I don't know why I can't let go!
Wait, I can't let go!
I actually...
Let go!
Wait!
I still have it!
Why is it like this?
I'm gonna stop making love to her!
Wait!
I still...
It's
like a little tiny dog and a stuffed animal.
I can't stop.
Mint has so many...
She has so much invisible burden on her.
What do I do with it?
What do I do?
What's going on?
Do we have to reset the lobby?
I don't know.
Hold on, let me leave.
No, it's still happening.
Maybe we should reset the lobby.
We'll reset the...
Jump on my block.
I can't even punch you.
Yeah, I'm invincible.
Wait, this might be game-breaking.
Like, what if I can...
Yeah, for real.
What if I can get through everything because I have an extra block?
Oh, it's lagging.
Is it also lagging, like, crazy on your side?
It's not lagging, though.
I'm just slow because I have this...
Okay, how about that?
Okay, let's go in!
We were just gonna stay like that?
Yeah.
Is that any way to live?
Mine, fan, poem.
Oh, I thought I was cured.
It's kind of game-breaking, though.
You can't play
it.
wait it is kind of lagging now yeah oh my god wait she's just i can't move i can't get out oh you can't go down blocked though okay let's restart the lobby okay how do i restart the lobby hold on oh my goodness let me let me uh yeah exit the game yeah oh my god what even happened how Why did you do that?
I don't know.
I saw it duplicate, like when I grabbed it earlier.
That's when I was like, wait a second.
Oh, you saw duplicate?
Yeah, and I was like, oh, maybe there's two of them.
And then I couldn't let go of it.
Oh, that's why you said there was two of them.
I was like, what's going on?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We broke it.
it's over you think that these people playing as us like we're so like this is hmm we're like the people on the title screen oh yeah like we're that we're just that gamer yeah i think it's us yeah actually they took our footage and yeah yeah we need we want royalties but oh do you send me a thing okay sorry i just saw it yeah yeah yeah no you know you're you're fine okay
man where's our royal tights saved right yeah yeah yeah i think so i'm pretty sure
what are you doing up there i'm i'm doing up here oh oh there you are okay oh no i'm should you host maybe my maybe my internet is not good no i don't think it's you i think it's fine now i did this before okay okay okay
Yeah, I missed my block.
I think your PC is haunted by someone other than you.
Makes sense.
All right.
Back to five.
Here we go.
Very well.
Oh, my God.
I forgot to capture the game.
Oh, oopsie.
Okay, okay.
Here we go.
No, we're good.
We're good.
Okay, the game won't break this time, everybody.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Oh, I should have gone.
Now Mint is playing.
Mint is now cheating at the battle block feeder.
Nice.
Like I died.
Ow, ow, ow.
Okay.
Hold on.
How do I...
Oh!
Oops.
Oh, my God.
How do you...
Oh, there you go.
Like that, yeah.
There you go.
Yeah.
And then up through.
Yep.
Noice.
Okay.
Nice.
Don't tell me what to do.
Okay.
I bounced off the wall.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
It's okay.
I'll throw you.
Wait.
Maybe you should grab it.
Yeah.
You should.
You get it.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
All right, there we go!
Yay!
Here we go!
Okay.
How do we get this guy, though?
Okay, how do you...
How do we...
Maybe something up there?
Oh, there's a boulder up here.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
Can you, can you, uh, get me up there?
There you go.
Oh, be careful.
Actually, you might have to...
I might have to...
Oh.
There you go.
No, not.
There we go.
Okay.
Very good.
Yay!
Okay, now I'm...
I grab it.
And then you go drop it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, nice.
And now I die.
Not, yeah.
Oh, you got it already.
Okay, good.
Now, now we, I'll throw you.
Throw me, oh, oops, try again.
Oh, oh, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Yeah, surely it won't happen again.
Oh, I can't do it.
Oh, yes, I can.
Oh, I know you're, oh, we got everything.
Oh, yay, that was fast.
Oops, there we go.
Okay, and then I...
I go here and I remove that.
Oh!
Okay.
Yep.
The game is a little laggy now, but that's okay.
Oops.
I don't know.
I feel like you should host then.
No, it's okay.
I think my...
Okay.
Well, she's just seeing stuff in gold vision.
Yeah.
I think we even time got that one.
No.
Apparently not.
I'm running.
Oh.
Oh, you need like a head, mega head start.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, no, you just run.
You just...
Oh.
Me?
Yeah?
Oh, oh, you like disappear from my VTube studio for a second.
What's going on?
My wife.
She's gone.
What's happening?
We're haunted!
We're haunted.
Okay, is this anything?
What's happening?
She went ghost.
She's going ghost.
Oh, good boy.
I made it anyway.
Okay, yeah, you're fine.
Oh, ow.
Oh, okay, that's not...
That's not how you do that.
Yeah, you're supposed to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm not locking in right now.
I think the game...
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
The game messing up...
You do not need to lock in.
It bugged me out, too, everybody.
I'm sorry.
It bugged you.
I bugged you.
Yeah, you bugged me.
Guys, if you believe in Mint Phantom, clap your hands.
Everybody clap your hands in chat.
I better see the clap emotes.
what why are we clapping our hands i don't know i just want to feel power
okay i'm gonna distract him you can get on the button okay okay i'll distract him i'll distract him i yeah get him over to the other side oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay i got it Okay.
Oh, but then he could...
Yeah.
Oh wait, here.
Yeah, yeah, wait.
And then...
Hold on.
He's after you.
Ah!
Okay, hold on.
Oh, oh, this is good.
This is good.
There you go.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, and then...
And then I'll make it...
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait.
Now you're trapped in there.
Do you?
What the heck?
No, yeah.
When it goes underneath, go.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're good.
Wee!
Bye!
Well, I still got it.
It's okay, it's good, it's okay.
Yeah, you got it.
Nice, nice.
Oh, it's one of these.
Okay, uh...
Okay.
You should be good.
Oh!
That was such an unlucky spawn.
Oh, cool.
We're fine.
Yeah, that was unlucky.
Okay.
Wait, sorry, I stopped.
I just stopped.
Okay, there we go.
Oops.
Oh, I tried to self-destruct.
I pressed the wrong button.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, nice!
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're gaming.
It's not that hard.
It's actually really easy.
All right, have some confidence.
Is there anything here?
Okay, no.
Why is that there?
Or maybe there is.
Nope.
That's fine.
You tried.
I tried.
Oh, oh, why did that blow up?
How mysterious.
it with my noggin your noggin my noggin wait a minute what should i have for dinner you should have oh i need to have you know what you should have ty food i have high in a minute that sounds good yeah oh you dropped that boy okay yeah yeah yeah okay over there?
You got it?
Yeah, no, I got everything, yeah.
Okay.
I always like Thai food.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, watch out.
Yeah!
Okay, I'm sure you... Oh, oh, I didn't notice.
Sorry.
I'll do it again.
I didn't see the handlebar.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't see it.
Everybody get Thai food right now.
If you're hungry and you're like, oh, what should I get for dinner?
Go get Thai food.
Right now.
Okay.
Oh, I got something.
Don't be a baby, you're alive.
Come on, come on up.
Wait, come on up, come on over.
You should...
Come on up.
Yeah, there you go.
Hello.
What?
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
I don't need you.
Oops.
My bad.
There's a jetpack!
There's a jetpack.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, you should...
I think you should jump on my head because I don't get enough...
Jump on my head.
Okay, nice.
Go!
Oh my god!
I got it!
Steak fried rice!
That sounds so good.
You telling me a steak fried this rice?
Yeah.
Yeah!
That's what he did, baby.
Hell yeah, baby!
You wanna buy?
We can buy, we can buy.
I don't know, do we have enough to buy?
I have no idea.
We probably have a million.
Oh, actually, we have enough to buy.
We have a tie.
Yeah, yeah.
You go first?
first okay okay i'm gonna go to the squares oh oh fuck god damn it oh gosh darn it oh i thought you meant to come up here on purpose no no no no okay oh man oh i like that one an electrical socket
oh why do you just keep getting guys i know oh and you got a baby and a house i got a house Oh, that's it.
Okay.
Let me try me.
All right, all right.
A guy.
Oh, big, big.
Whoa, your ears.
They're your ears.
Oh, I like it.
Nerd.
Ooh.
Wait, I got the old guy, too.
Yeah, you got the guy.
I got the old guy, too.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm going to buy more weapons.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to buy more weapons.
You got the frog!
You got the frog?
Where is that?
What is that?
What'd you get?
I don't know.
Oh, I got an airplane.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, it's a boomerang.
Oh, a boomerang.
Does it kill?
Oh, it stuns!
I'm hitting the baby.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm hitting the baby.
I don't want anything that stuns, though.
I think my fireball is the best option still.
Yeah, you going, uh, kamehameha.
I don't know how I just got back home, but I did.
Somehow, some way.
Just the baby.
Wait, are these people?
Hey, what are these guys doing?
Oh, wait.
You're right.
I guess, like, maybe we just...
Because...
Yeah, I think they're protesting.
testing because maybe we're we're so good at the game that they're like this isn't fun to watch oh yeah they're like hey kill these guys already yeah kill these guys oh oh oh oh oh oh oh are you stuck there now yep you're you're in baby jail oh oopsie oh oh okay wait you got oh there you go
we're supposed to go go go nice i have to wait oh no i'm stuck oh you forgot that's messed up oh thank you okay there you go now oh you're supposed to go icy yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay all right and then oh i see and then oh but no oh oh yes oh i i guess you i okay oh oh no uh hmm yeah oh damn oh no no we're trapped in baby jail okay i'll be trapped in baby jail oh i see i think where i have to okay i see where i have to go there we go nice nice nice okay okay wait um okay i'm gonna wait there we go okay okay okay okay man i do this Oh!
And then...
And then you can just climb up here.
You can just climb up here.
Okay, okay.
I think so.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, we made it.
It's fine.
We made it.
Shhh.
All right.
We're fine.
Oh!
Nice.
Nice!
Oh.
Wait, that looks like a secret.
Yeah, that's a secret.
There you go.
Jump!
You got it.
Okay.
There was also a teleporter down...
But I...
Maybe we missed it.
Because I feel like it was a while ago.
Maybe?
Oh, there was?
I didn't see it.
Ah!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Get out of here!
Stop!
Kill him!
Uh, my...
My, uh, my dart!
Um, oh, oh, uh, how do we get- Oh, they're gone, they're gone.
There we go, there we go.
Says we go, uh, uh...
Ow!
Oh no!
Oh, what- There was a guy.
Okay.
Oops, oopsie, I got stunned.
Oh, hey, I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna kill you.
Kill him, kill him!
Yeah, kill him!
I killed him!
I killed his air!
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Oh, you're on fire?
That's okay.
Oh, wait.
No, I have to get back up there.
Shoot.
It's okay.
But we don't have that guy anymore, so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You don't have to worry about him.
Okay.
Nice.
And then... I think you get rid of this thing.
Oh, I got rid of this thing, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
And then over here.
I think I still...
There you go.
Oh, yeah.
But then we're missing... We're missing one of the jewels.
the bottom but maybe it's maybe we just passed it oh i didn't know that opened up like that okay oh i'm stuck actually wait i'm just
yay we're so good at the game we're so oh there's only like four anyways five We got five.
We're so good at this dang game, man.
I know.
They should just, like, they should just pay us.
Wait, did we go the right way?
Don't, don't, don't!
Oh, okay.
I thought you were blocking me.
There you go.
Now give me the rock.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh.
I think it killed me.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Yeah, that's easier.
Did it kill you?
The rock did, maybe.
But maybe I wasn't supposed to drop it.
Oh my god!
I made it.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, you made it.
You got it.
Everything's fine.
Everything is okay.
How do you get through this?
Nothing's okay.
Oh, how did you do that?
How did you do that?
What the hell?
I think I keep breaking the game.
How do we get that though?
Oh, now we go this way.
But how do we...
There should be a way to get that, right?
Oh, there's like a secret thing there maybe.
Where?
Somewhere.
There's something that there's a launcher above here.
Yeah, I know, but how do we get in there?
I don't know.
Uh...
Oops.
Oh, like here and then...
How do you...
How would you...
How?
How do you...
How would you?
How?
If you had a... If you had a dream that was so real and you could have a... Do anything, what would you do?
What would you do?
Oops, I tried the same.
hack as before.
The same hack sores.
Get on my body.
Lay on my body.
I'm laying.
Why did it put me up here?
Okay.
Oops.
Nice.
Oh.
No.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
It's like you die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Die.
Okay, nice.
I don't think that's how we're supposed to do it, but... But we do it.
Maybe like over here?
No?
What?
How do you get over there?
drop okay oh my god you're so freaking smart oh my god you're so freaking smart oh my god of course of course i did it big brain big brain she did it oh how the hell did you do it bro wait you like i was like crawling my body
Oh, no, I was doing that.
It looked like you were getting, like, raptured for a second.
I screamed.
You were just floating above.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I have...
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Okay, send me?
Yep.
Oh, I thought I was getting sent.
Okay.
Oh, go, go, go.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh, wait, wait.
No, get back on those buttons.
Kill yourself.
Oh, oh, oh.
What did you say?
Sacrifice herself.
How would she say this?
What the heck?
It's out of blood.
all right oh my god the game is glitching so bad for me berry bug really oh no what do we do yeah it's glitching bad bad oh no is it like unplayable no it's just a little awkward oh okay okay well let me know if you want to maybe we can we can wrap up here too for the day yeah the first time we played it was I don't know.
Then we're glitching.
Yeah, I don't know.
Like we got through so many levels.
No, I think we can keep going.
I did get a new computer during that time.
So maybe like my internet like is messed up now?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Oh my god, my computer.
One second.
Oh, it's time.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, my Wi-Fi antenna is plugged in.
I use Wi-Fi.
I didn't want to say it because I know- I don't, I didn't want to say it because I know people were gonna say something, but I, yeah, I'm- I use Wi-Fi.
Okay, I think I should host the game.
Ooh, oh.
I didn't want to say- I don't know what you're gonna be like.
Oh.
Wait, there's a- there's a secret up there.
Do you want to- do you want to reset now?
Oh, I see.
You got it.
No, let's do it after this level.
Now go through.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
God damn it.
Why did you have to...
Why did you have to out me like that, man?
What's wrong with you?
Oh, no.
I don't think I can get through.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, thank you.
I did it.
I shut it off.
Okay.
What's wrong?
Nothing's wrong with having Wi-Fi.
Okay?
Wi-Fi is what our...
Your computers were originally built on before you were a computer nerd, okay?
Anyone
good?
Okay, I'm turning...
Oh, it puts me back right...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Oh, I see too.
Oops.
You got it?
Okay, I'll go next.
Okay, you got it?
You got it?
This still launched me.
Oh, we're fine.
It's okay.
We're fine.
I don't have to do anything properly.
Oh, oh, ah, okay, okay.
Okay, it's because I have the Wi-Fi, the Wi-Fi buff.
Yeah, clearly.
I'm hosting on Wi-Fi.
Oh, dang it!
I almost had it.
I got it.
I got it, you got it.
We got it!
Yeah, we got it!
All right.
I'm trapped.
Yeah.
A host buff.
Yeah, the host buff.
The host buff.
And the wrong Wi-Fi.
We'll reset the lobby.
Again for the third time.
It's okay.
It's so that Mint can have zero ping.
I don't even know what cat I have.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Do you want to...
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
I think I have to hide the game, right?
You don't have to.
I don't think it shows anything, but just in case, maybe.
Okay.
Online play.
Fine.
Uh...
Oh, host player.
Yeah.
And then friends only or private.
Public lobby.
I think you should pick cool things and not dumb and stupid things.
And now how do I invite you?
Oh, here we go.
Invite friends.
Wait, did you do public lobby?
Yes.
So you don't do public lobby.
You better hurry up.
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't.
What did you do?
Wait, why do I join?
Okay.
I sent you the invite.
Okay, okay, thank you, thank you.
Jesus Christ!
I didn't do public lobby.
Oh, okay.
Why do you feel so good about lying to me?
Yes!
So messed up.
She's so messed up, man.
It's because I love you.
Let me know if it's laggy on your end of it.
I don't feel it.
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, we were one.
I do.
do see yeah i kind of do see what's going on now yeah remember when i said berry bug i'm inside you i didn't know that the game was actually yeah she was telling the future you guys wow i saw the future wow oh my god where we was i inside you again a little bit a little bit wait so there's chapter five i'll save you having yeah so there are six levels or six chapters or i feel like the next chapter should be the last one because the the next like the next area is just outside for some reason i remember people saying eight though i don't remember maybe eight like as in the final maybe there was originally six oh wow we both really just wow can we cut that from the board i need you Okay.
Oh, oops I died.
Oh, okay, it's okay.
I'm like all the way back.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I need help.
I need...
I need... I need...
She needs assistance!
I need assistance!
Wait, you think there's a secret down there?
Oh, there is!
And it's an easier way to get up, baby!
Heck yeah.
Yeah.
Oops.
It's okay.
Oh, wait.
Can't get it.
I need you.
I can't.
I...
I'm stuck.
I need you, Mint.
I'm alive yourself.
I'm alive.
I'm stuck.
Wait, hold on.
I'm alive.
Dang it.
That would work.
There you go.
And then I need you to...
Nice!
Woo!
Oh, that's how you get through.
Oh, wait, is there anything down here?
No.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I believe in you.
Me too.
Oh, I did it.
Okay, nice.
Oh, wait.
What the?
Oh, ah!
Can we slide under that?
How do we get under that?
I feel like it's too...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can do it this time.
Ah!
Oh, oh.
Nice.
Oh.
Wait.
Get down!
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Up?
I think you need me.
I think so, too.
I need you, I need you!
I need you!
Okay.
Wait, how though?
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go!
We're coming.
Yeah, yeah.
Is this anything?
Oh, yes.
Ah.
Um, he's shooting.
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, I got it.
Get me!
Oh!
You hit me!
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Ow.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Kill that bozo.
Um, I was gonna say, yeah, that's why I went back up.
That's why I went back up.
Oh, is it everything?
Yep, that's everything.
It is, yeah.
Okay.
Yippee!
Yo, yo, yo, yo!
Yo, yo!
Oh, wait.
You're not on the...
Oh, my bad.
I thought I heard...
I thought we both got...
Sorry.
I thought that this was...
I thought you were waiting for me.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, man.
What if I, like, destroyed...
What if we had time there?
And I destroyed our time.
I would never forgive you.
Someone calculate the time on that.
someone do that no wait wait wait wait wait i think you go to the go to or or can you can you drag the thing off why i'm gonna kill us so that i can go on the bottom wait no or maybe we should there's also go no no go down go down there i'm gonna okay there you go bye but then how do you but oh but then i do this okay wait isn't there a secret behind that thing too though what thing i think the behind the the thing you just pulled the block oh maybe but i can't pull it anymore oh wait never mind it's probably not i think you're right though no maybe i don't maybe not maybe not yet Maybe we get there.
Okay,
nice.
I don't know what this does.
Oh, I think I'm gonna kill you.
It's supposed to hold...
Yeah, it's supposed to hold me.
Here, I'll just...
I'll just...
Okay.
And then...
Supposed to do this.
Wait.
There we go.
Yeah, so that you can go over there.
I just want to make sure that there's no...
Oh, no, you got it.
Okay.
Yeah, I got it.
Wait, what?
I don't know.
I don't actually get it though.
I don't actually understand, I think.
I think I'm actually quite confused.
Uh...
Where we, uh...
Oh, I see right here, right here.
Oh, okay.
Wait, no, but that's not us.
Oh, wait, no, we just started the saw.
We started the saw.
I see.
Follow me, follow the leader, follow the leader.
Oh, oh, get it!
Ah, you got it!
I got it!
Woo!
Oh, don't be like me.
Oh, how'd you do that?
We're both hacking.
What's going on?
Okay, I got it.
Okay, I'm coming to you.
Oh, I die.
I've got to die.
Oh, wait.
There's a secret in there.
Don't die.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I'm here.
Okay, how did I land?
Oh, I'm just safe.
Oh, dang it.
Wait, what the?
How did I get down here?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah, I got down here.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, you got it.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
I made it, though.
Wait, oh.
Wait, wait.
Okay.
What's going on?
Wait,
why is it sending me over that way?
Okay.
Okay, you got it.
You got it?
Oh, I don't have it.
Wait, oh, this is so much easier.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, nothing.
Ah!
Dude, die.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay.
How are you supposed to make this?
No.
Wait, am I dumb?
You're supposed to, like, time it.
Chat, I think I'm stupid.
It's tricky.
No, you're not.
No, don't say that, but my friend, Minto!
Oh, oh my gosh, I can't...
I got stuck.
Okay.
A big head.
It's okay.
Your big head is lovable.
Oh, there you go, you made it.
I made it!
Oh, okay, you're good.
I don't know.
Oh, this part is kind of...
Ah, I mistimmed it.
Ah, oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
I made it.
Oh, you made it!
What the heck?
How'd you do that?
Ah!
Hi.
I made it again.
And I'll do it again.
Whatever.
Oh my god.
Don't...
Not in the phantom.
Where did it put me?
Where'd it go?
No.
Don't do this.
I didn't put you over there.
I don't know.
Wait, why did it put me?
Stop.
Man, I need you to move.
Okay, okay.
What are these spawns?
Oh, nice.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Wow.
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
We did it.
What is this?
We have one more to the boss.
Yeah.
The iconic duo, Mint Phantom, and Rabie Survivor.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I don't think that's working.
It will one day.
Oh!
It's gonna work!
It's gonna work now!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
We got it.
Oh!
You were definitely in my way.
I see, I see.
Ah, no!
I was so close!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Never punished, baby.
Never punish baby.
Never punish...
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, how do you get through this?
Ah!
Wait, what is the...
Wait, get off the platform.
Oh, my bad.
What's the point of this area?
Oh, there's a teleporter!
Oh, I see it now.
I didn't notice it before.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh God.
Ah!
Where'd I go?
Oh, hello.
Okay.
No ice?
Easy peasy, lemon squeezy.
Yeah, our our chibi models, oh.
Our chibi models are by hexos.
Yeah, oh.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
It's just a massacre.
What the heck?
How do you do this?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh, what?
Okay.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Oh, you're so good.
You're dead.
But you're so good.
I did it.
It's fine.
You did it.
I did it.
I did it twice.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Hey!
Oh!
Oh, go, go!
Wait, how are you supposed to do this for me?
I think maybe we're supposed to go on the blue thing and you throw me over maybe.
But I made it really well.
Oh, okay, there we go.
Oh, okay, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, get back, get back here.
I will try.
Okay, okay, now.
Okay, nice.
Woohoo!
Okay, what's going on here?
Yeah, that seems like a secret.
It does, right?
Yeah, what the heck?
We're like so paranoid now.
I know, everything is secret.
Okay, maybe Maybe not.
You got it?
Good job.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, okay.
What is this?
Did this do anything?
I think it lifts it up.
Oh, you think so?
Beam me up!
Barry!
Oh, just kidding.
I think it's automatic.
Wait, maybe not?
Oh, okay, okay.
Go.
Oh, oh.
Maybe that's...
Oh, it goes too.
Okay, it's a little...
Oh.
Okay.
Um...
Okay, okay.
There's flaws.
Okay, okay, okay.
Just dodge.
Oh, I see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice.
Okay, now your turn.
Okay, my turn.
Just dodge.
Just dodge forehead.
Yeah, just dodge.
Just dodge.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Whoa, Spider-Man!
Spider-Bog!
Ah!
okay very good very good you ever say that like i'm doing very good today
no i do say sometimes when i wake up in the style of good mental morning i do say a very good morning but i'm i feel like i'm like an english like a talky english is it because you're You're never feeling very good?
No, it's because who says a very good morning to you?
Wait, I think you have to launch.
I think I launched you.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Launch me.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, go.
Top of the morning tree.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
I'm in a paper boat.
No, I think you're good.
I think you're good.
You just have to drag it down.
I can't.
Oh.
Wow!
Oh, okay.
Here you go.
Okay, go.
You got it.
Yeah, I get his ass.
Okay.
Oh.
That's so messed up.
I'm gonna kill everybody and myself.
Don't do it, Vince.
Don't do it.
Those wisps and bug bros have a family.
Okay.
Oh.
Push.
Oops.
There you go.
Nice.
Now we got everything.
Oh.
Why is that everything?
Yeah, I think so.
Why did you get up there?
Why invite...
I'm all for trouble.
Hello?
I'm pushing it higher.
Yeah, I think if it...
I think if you keep staying on it, it doesn't go as hot.
You have to like continuously jump on it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or maybe not.
Maybe not.
I don't understand.
Or maybe not.
I don't know.
Okay, I'm gonna set it up.
You got it!
Oh, there you go.
Huh?
All right, boss time.
I punched you the baby.
I said the baby, I'm fine.
All right.
Oh.
I was scratching my nose.
Oh my god.
I wish I was there.
Oh, I wish I could just ride on your head.
Yeah, imagine.
Oh, okay, okay.
We got lock-in.
All right, lock-in, lock-in, lock-in.
Lock-in, lock-in.
Okay.
Oh.
Cut that out.
We're still locked in.
We're still locked in no matter what.
Okay, I got it.
I don't know what.
We're good.
Oh, no.
Oh, keep continuing.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Why did you spawn there?
I don't know.
Oh, the game hates me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, I was on your head.
Okay, okay, we're fine, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Okay, nice.
Anything here?
Nothing here?
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to go now.
What is that?
Jump on my head.
Okay, I'm jumping.
Okay.
I take the boulder off.
Okay, okay.
And then, I don't think you go that way anymore.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
I see!
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wait, how do I get out of this?
How do I...
What are you doing?
I don't know how to get out of this.
You might have to just die.
You might just have to die.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay, nice.
What do you want?
You got the checkpoint over there, though.
Yeah, that's so messed up.
Just keep going.
Okay, I'm going.
Okay, okay.
The wind, the wind.
Oh, I see.
You have to climb.
Okay, okay, nice, nice.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
The rocks are gonna fall.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, God.
Oh, God, oh, that's a lot of rocks.
There's a lot of rocks.
Nothing up here?
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Wait, um...
Oh, did we... did we mess up now?
Wait, did I mess up?
Oh, I guess we...
No, no, no, no, we met...
We, we...
It was a group effort.
It's okay, we're just still.
Wait.
We don't need everything.
Yeah, we don't need everything!
What the...
Help!
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, I can't see...
Oh, why did it spawn me there?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Let's fly straight!
Oh, I'm at the top!
How did I get here?
Help!
Why is it so hard to fly?
Oh, oh, I got it, I got it.
You're at the top!
We got it!
Yippee!
Wait, there's like a capa.
Oh, he's cute.
What the heck?
I think you're stuck.
I'm stuck.
Oh, okay, there we go.
Okay.
I think that was everything.
There was an emerald there.
Oh, he like walked.
Okay, QQ.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get it.
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
Now we're thinking with my...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, my timing is all...
It's okay, it's okay.
We just have to go to the goal now.
We just have to go to the goal.
Yeah, we just have to get to the goal.
Yeah, we have to get to the goal.
Just get to the goal.
Ah!
Ah, wait!
No!
Ow.
Okay.
Nice.
There's an emerald over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, uh...
Oops.
Oh, do I need to throw you?
What?
Go!
Oh, don't go.
Oh, oops.
I also was able to just jump over there, to be honest.
Like that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we just... The timing is all off.
The timing is all off!
Okay, okay.
You got it!
Okay, nice, nice.
Okay, just continue.
You just continue.
No, I got the emerald.
I got the emerald.
Oh, you did?
Oh, just kidding.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, dang
it.
You got it?
Okay, okay.
Okay.
All right.
Remove.
Okay.
All right.
We'll get trapped.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Go, go, go, go.
All right.
Okay, we're good.
The boulders are coming!
Get the diamond!
Get it!
I got it!
Okay!
Go!
Where am I?
Oh, I was...
Oh, yeah, I did.
Okay.
Where am I?
I got this.
Oh, I didn't!
Oh my gosh, you're right.
Oops.
It's okay.
Uh, I think I have to wait for him to...
Yeah, turn it off.
There you go.
Okay.
Goodbye.
All right.
Hello.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go.
All right, we're at the end here.
We have plenty of...
Oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
We have plenty of time now.
Oops, oops, oops, oops.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, hold on, okay.
Oops, oops.
Okay.
There's a ball at the end, so don't go on the actual, don't go on the ending thing.
Oh my God, it undone!
Ah, it was right there because I was waiting.
close.
I could see it by the hair on your chinny chin chin.
I got the ball.
Just go in.
Okay, okay.
We just have to go on the we just have to go on the the final thing.
Yeah, just get in there.
Freak, freak, freak, freak, freak, freak.
Sorry, not you, not you.
I'm just trying to not curse.
Okay.
Oops, oops, and then they're climbing wrong.
Have you gotten over there even once, Barry?
Can we not talk?
I was there last time.
Okay.
I don't need to prove anything.
Ah!
Wait, wait, wait!
Oh, you already got the ball!
Okay.
I forgot.
Oh.
Ah!
Okay.
Well, we got that.
What is...
What's exploding?
The job?
Okay, nice.
Oops, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
You're okay?
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, okay.
Oh, man.
This is rough.
I'm trying.
We got it.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Is there any secrets?
No secrets?
I don't think there's actually secrets.
Oh, oops.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
You got to slide.
That should count.
Freak!
Oh, oops.
Okay, it's okay.
It's good.
Okay.
Nice!
Oh, I had it!
I did slide.
Oh!
Good job!
Okay, you got it, you got it.
Nice.
Okay, I don't know how I got that.
Thank you.
I used your head, I think.
Okay, cool.
Okay, whatever works.
Whatever works.
I made it somehow.
Okay, nice.
Keep going, keep going.
Okay, I'm going.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Watch out here.
Okay.
I'm going through you.
Okay, nice.
Good job, good job.
No!
Don't follow me!
Ah!
Oh gosh, okay.
Oh, dang it, I didn't notice it.
It's so hard to see with like the little exclamation points everywhere.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think I got it.
Dang it!
Okay, you got it.
Just keep going, just keep going.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
And then- Oh, we gotta go down.
Oh, we gotta slide.
We gotta be down.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I stopped.
Oops.
Uh, whatever.
Just stop.
I don't know.
I came to a stop.
Okay.
I'm going.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
I got it.
Oh my god, you're so fucking good.
Oh, okay, okay.
Wait, hold on.
Don't jinx it.
Oh, yeah, it's okay.
Sorry, I should have said it.
Okay.
Oh, I'm not good.
Just keep going.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, keep going.
Oh my gosh, wait, there's, oh, I didn't notice that, okay.
Emphid!
It vexes me so.
It truly does.
But where did it come from?
Well, children, some say the hat was blessed by a voodoo witch doctor.
And then cursed by another voodoo witch doctor like 30 minutes later.
I'm gonna eat goldfish.
Without me?
When he found the hat perched atop a giant ruby.
A ruby that naturally formed into the shape of a skull.
A human skull.
Oh.
I think the hat is haunted by all the souls of its previous owners.
By you?
All of their dreams and failures mashed together.
I've never had that hat.
Oh.
Well, I guess if you ever have a future outfit where there's a hat, it's gonna be a little suspicious.
Stuff I've ever heard in my entire life, but I'm the dumb one.
That's fine.
And not just anyone can dom the hat you know.
It calls out only to those who embody the exemplary qualities required.
Ah, so it only corrupts pure souls.
Like us.
Oh, so I definitely can have this hat.
Yeah, yeah.
Me too.
That's preposterous.
And heavyweighs the crown.
He who wears the hat calls the shots and in a time long forgotten maintain balance and ensure that everyone was plump and happy and wanted for nothing.
But all good things come to an end, children.
Well, that's not entirely true.
I figure pizza will always exist.
But this hat, let's just say it's days of benevolent You don't really...
I feel like...
A lot of games nowadays try to establish this type of like narrative style where it's like very quirky.
But I feel like they don't really...
They don't really get it like this.
Yeah, I get it.
Yeah, right?
Like it always feels like too cringe, but this feels like cringe in a good way.
This is cringe, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
I need you more than ever now.
I guess maybe it's just the fact that it's like more indie feeling.
Yeah, not a lot of games.
It feels authentic where like new games are like quirky to be quirky.
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It feels very corporate the other game.
Yeah.
I think we escape after this.
I think so too.
I think we're gonna escape.
Yeah.
That cat's looking at me.
Wait, what's on the other side?
What's over here?
It's a locked back yard.
Yeah, I think we're escaping after this.
What's a piece?
You see him here?
It's hopeless.
Oh, oh, oh, wait.
They're protesting.
Oh my god, they're Hattie.
Oh my god.
Shame on Hattie Hattieton.
What?
Oh my god.
I know what I did.
Okay.
Oh, whoa.
It's like that one Neopets.
Oh my god, I know exactly what you're talking about.
Oh, okay.
Oh, be careful!
Just kidding.
Wait, is it that way?
Oops.
Oh, wait, wait.
There's like something up here, I think.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, that might be something.
Yeah, try.
Nice.
Oh, I think I need you.
I think I need you.
Okay, I'm coming.
Wait, but then we can also go this way as a team.
Yeah, this is like the most...
It's like open-ended.
What the heck?
Oops.
Oh, yeah, which way do we want to go then?
I guess I could just go this way since we already kind of started it.
Oh, I'm so bad at this.
It's okay.
I hate wall jump.
Please.
You just have to keep going on the slime.
I know.
If I could reach the slime.
Slime, slime, slime.
You got it, you got it.
Yeah, you got it, you got it, you got it.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh, be careful.
We just have to...
Do you want to launch me or should I launch you?
I'll launch you.
Come here.
No!
It should have been you.
I mean, well, not really, but like, you know...
Whoa, Minto.
Whoa!
Okay, wait, so what's the plan?
You launch me?
I'll launch you!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, go.
So close.
Thank you.
all right i'm going at a reasonable pace over there yeah oh oh there we go oh this is why we go at reasonable paces all right jump on my head yeah we need to take my head okay i'm jumping hold on my head i'm on my head okay okay okay don't jump on my head don't jump on my head okay hold on oh i got it go okay i got it got it got it you got it nice i think that's it probably yeah that's it that's it oh wait there's something here though oh wait you're right no no that that's probably the ball teleport yeah yeah but there's something down here it looks like where the here oh there's definitely something yeah yeah yeah right yeah oh i saw it okay you got it nice nice nice nice nice okay cool cool Good spot,
good find.
How do we get over?
There's another gem above.
Yeah, I know.
Jump on my head.
Oh, I got it.
Go, go, go.
Okay, nice.
Okay, what is...
You got it?
Yep.
Nice, nice.
Alright, alright.
We're gaming now.
We're thinking with portals.
Yeah, we're thinking with portals.
Um...
Oh, I guess we just take the...
Hoi!
Ah!
I don't The boulders seem kind of crazy I It's not just me It's not just me everybody Oh no What is it supposed to I don't understand what we're supposed to do though I think maybe we have to go back around to that other part that we Skip Yeah but in order We need to bring the boulder up Up to the thing Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
So maybe...
So pick it up.
Hold on.
Yeah, grab that.
And then, and then...
Whoa, wait, hold on.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
Who could have seen that coming?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
There we go.
And then, and then...
Okay, do that.
Alright.
Throw it.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
My turn.
Okay, now...
No, wait, why?
Because we have to move these, I guess, again.
Oh, so it stops.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
I'm on the back.
Barry, if I move.
Okay, okay, okay.
You do the bolder thing because I think you're better at it.
Push it close.
There we go.
Okay, I need you to go the other way.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, go.
Okay.
Then we take...
We take a...
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oops.
There we go.
And then, wait, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
Okay.
Oh, whoa.
What?
Why are you going on?
I don't know.
Wait, keep going.
Wait.
Keep doing that.
Because then you could have just...
Oh!
Sorry.
I didn't...
It's okay.
Okay.
Just all according to Keikaku.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
How do I...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, now jump.
Oh, what?
Yeah, jump with me on it.
Or you should have been holding it.
There we go.
This works too.
Yeah, this kind of works.
Oh!
It's okay, it's okay.
One more time.
One more time!
Right on your dead body.
Okay.
You slipped Why does it kill you like that?
I don't know Okay, don't move it, don't move it.
I'm not, I'm not Okay, okay, I'm moving you up Okay, hold on Alright, I'm not gonna move it Okay, I believe I'm not gonna move it Okay, and then wait, not gonna move it Okay, okay, okay Okay, okay Okay, okay Uh-oh.
Wait, hold on.
Uh...
There we go, there we go.
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god, that scared the heck out of me!
Hey!
Oh, that should be my, I...
Hey, we worked hard for...
We both worked hard for it.
What is this upset?
You gonna eat?
Be careful?
I'm... I'm...
I'm...
Okay.
I'm being so careful right now.
It's okay though.
You have the help!
Wait, why did the music stop when you...
Everybody hated that.
What the heck?
I got it.
First try.
Shut up!
Okay, how do we... Where do we go?
Or I guess maybe you throw me?
Oh, hold on.
This way.
Okay.
Nope.
That way.
Okay.
Okay, little baby.
Come on, little baby.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm getting pissed off.
Hold on.
My dad is collateral damage.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What the, what the, what the, what the?
What the?
happen i don't know just keep going okay okay uh ow ow okay now what oh oh oh we're supposed to move it over there wait okay there we go oh oh oh oh my oh my god oh my god he wasn't a problem anymore yes he was he was a problem oh shit oh yes he killed me oh we're done yeah we're done You're just beating up the robot.
I have a lot of internal aggression.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, man.
I thought that I could kill him.
Yeah, you know, I really believe that you could kill him though.
It really seemed like you almost killed him.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Uh, alright.
cool oh oh i see i see okay i'll stay here you go what do i do uh oh okay i don't know oh maybe uh when you jump oh when you jump um i'll get off the button oh like that that yeah right okay okay ready yep nice okay and then i guess i you stay on that and then i'll Nice?
Oh, nice?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I need to stay on it.
Okay.
There you go.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, then I do this.
There is a secret.
Sorry.
Oh, I think I'm trapped.
Oh, just keep going.
Okay, I'll just keep going.
What the hell is that?
I don't know if you want to go.
Yeah, we should go.
We should go.
Wait, so we're this way.
Where is it?
Where is it little guy?
Where is it, guy.
This way?
up?
Oh!
I think, I guess it is up.
Um, I don't think we can get through.
You might have to take one for the team.
Okay.
Where did that?
Oh, well.
Is he, is he chilling?
Oh, wait, no, we just go here.
Hello!
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Okay, now you can go to the other side.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, the other side!
Yeah, no, stay there, stay there, stay there.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, stay there.
can't get past him though yeah just stay there stay hold on lead him over lead him over uh i think our guys oh oh wait he's really stupid oh oh i'll do it i'll sacrifice myself okay now you go i taste better than you apparently okay and then you go down there okay but wait but our secret Yeah,
our secrets were done.
Oh, okay.
No, no, no.
It was nothing.
The secret!
It was nothing at all.
Oh.
I made
it.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Good job, good job.
There's nothing else over there.
It's just a loop.
Okay, okay.
Oops, I still died.
It's okay.
I don't know how to...
How do you...
Oh, you probably push this, like, here, and then you...
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh!
What the...
Woo!
Okay, like that.
Wait, wait, wait.
Come as close as you can to the one I'm at.
Okay.
Oh, ah!
I should have let go.
I should have let...
Maybe?
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Do it again, do it again.
What?
Oh, oh, you were so close.
Okay.
Go!
Yay!
Nice!
Oh, that was perfect.
Okay, okay.
What did that do?
I don't know.
Oh, we got the yarn from it.
Oh, we missed the secret.
Where is the secret?
Oh, good job.
Oh, you got both of them though.
Thank you.
Maybe no secret.
No, there has to be.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh.
Oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh,
yeah, yeah, do that.
Oh, okay, I killed us.
Oh, wait, we missed the secret.
Where is the secret?
I think it was maybe in the beginning?
I think so.
We can just complete the level and then come back if we want.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mito stuck!
Alright, so the second level had a secret.
Yeah.
Alright.
Launch me.
Sorry.
Okay.
I'll...
Wait!
Okay.
Yeah, goop yourself.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, you'll die.
There's a death trap.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my, oh my.
Oh my god.
I hit himself.
Very good.
Stupid.
Whoa.
How did you get over?
Sound like a monkey in the wild.
Oh my god.
What's going on over here?
Ah!
Come on, man.
I fell and I died, but I'm here and it's fine.
We're here now.
Jump on my head.
Oh, I still have a knife for some reason.
Why have a knife?
Okay, jump.
Wait.
Yeah.
Okay, get up.
Get up.
You get it.
Oh, you got it.
You got it.
Okay.
Now what?
Jump onto the...
Oh, oh, I see.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay, close.
Okay.
Ow.
It requires a finesse.
Okay.
Oh!
I think you can climb...
Can you...
It requires a certain lady's touch.
Uh...
You gotta stop talking, man.
You got this?
Go, go, go, go up.
Okay.
Oops.
Oh, good bye.
Oh, God, no.
No!
That
is so terrible.
Okay.
This one's hard.
This is, like, actual hard, man.
It, like, jumped up and...
What's that?
I don't know.
What is that?
A little something something.
Wait, is that the song?
What song is so important if you're making up a song.
I know.
Wait, what are you saying right now?
What are you saying?
We'll take back the regular minto.
Who are you?
Okay.
Oops.
How are we overthinking this?
Like...
No, you're supposed to, like, go through the thingies...
Yeah, you're supposed to go through the thingies...
Oops.
Like, one at a time.
Like, threading the...
Like, Flappy Bird.
You're supposed to Flappy Bird.
I'm pretty sure.
Flappy Bird.
You have Flappy Bird on your...
Flappy Bird!
You know, Flappy Bird!
Flappy Bird, man!
Flappy Bird!
You know, Flappy Bird!
Oops.
Ow.
Oh, my God.
It keeps putting me underneath the spikes because it hates me.
Yeah, I don't, this is tough.
Guys, welcome to the finale of Battle Block Theater where it's just us on this screen for 30 minutes until we stop playing.
Is that what it is?
I just double jump to control my jump a little bit more.
Yeah, but it's hard.
It is tough.
You're supposed to Mega Man this what does that mean?
Make a million!
That means, like, really platform.
It means I'm money smart, not book smart.
Makes me more intelligent.
Ah.
No.
Hey!
What?
No.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, hold on.
Ow.
Uh, oh.
I see the vision.
I just think the skill is.
is not...
No!
Wait, why didn't you put it there again and it saves us a step?
I can't get the second...
No, you can just do the one and we can just jump over top of it.
Oh, oh, oh, you're right.
Oh my gosh, this is so tough!
Oops.
Oh my god, that's what I'm saying.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, jump in my head.
Okay, okay.
Now...
Only one of us has to make it though.
Wait, let me jump on your head again.
Oh, you made it.
Oops.
I don't know how I got the edge, the edge glitch.
I know.
Oh my gosh.
Ow.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
We are...
You think we're gonna get this?
time on this?
I think we might get, like, negative time.
Oh, dang it.
I was trying to get it, too.
Oops.
Wait, what if...
What am I getting hit by?
Yeah?
What if we both were on the thing at the same time?
What thing?
This thing?
No, the fire block.
Oh, this thing.
Okay.
Oops.
If I could get there.
Okay, okay, you got it.
Oh, oh, oh.
is that does that help yes maybe okay okay i'm gonna oh fuck okay okay okay
okay this is tough what get on me get on me get on me and jump oh okay get on me and jump there's no timer for these levels but yeah luckily thank god luckily yeah i don't want to come back here even for the secret okay hold on oh let me try and figure out how to
time it's like the spikes are this he's fucking with us right now I think he's only appeared any time we spent like too long on something yeah I
think I figured it out!
Wait, you did too!
Oops!
Oh my god!
Wait, what is this supposed to do?
Oh, I don't know.
Let me get this first.
Oh my god!
I have to...
Oh.
We did it!
Yippee!
What's this?
Oh, what?
A kappa?
Oh, oh, oh.
Uh...
Okay.
I'm willing to try anything now.
Yeah, we did it.
Oh, that's me.
Oh my god.
There's like a million of them.
Oh, wait, where am I?
Oh, ouch.
Okay.
Oh, you got the hat.
Oh, I died.
Don't let the hat.
Don't let the hat die.
No.
I think only...
I think it only dies if you're, if you go into the water.
Yeah.
Well.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
Let me try!
No!
I want the hug!
Oh, I pressed the wrong button anyway.
Ah, damn it.
Got it.
I've planted myself here.
Do we get all the jewels though?
I think?
Oh, no, we did it.
Oh, no, there's one there.
There's one there.
I can get it.
You don't want to lose your precious hand.
I know.
I haven't had one the whole stream.
I didn't either.
You got this?
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
You got it?
I'm trying.
Why is there water right in front?
Oh, my gosh.
No, no, you're not gonna die.
It's okay.
You're you're a gamer Now I have pressure Barry Now there's pressure on me my whole family is everybody clap if you believe in Minto Everybody clap if you believe
They're saying clap clap clap clap You got it you got it.
Shit.
Oh You got it.
See you got it
They believed in you.
It was all due to your powers, everybody.
And whoever said, I don't, I hope you don't play the lottery.
How long were we on that one level?
I know, that took, I feel like that took like an hour, man.
For real.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Is this gonna be messed up like the other one?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I think you gotta launch me.
Yeah, okay.
And I gotta kill him.
Yeah, kill him.
Kill him.
Okay, nice.
Oops.
I gotta die.
You gotta die?
Oh, you blocked us.
You blocked us.
I know, I know.
Uh-oh.
Why me?
You just gotta dodge, man.
I'm gonna kill you.
What I do?
Oh my god, it's Donkey Kong!
Okay, oops.
Oh my goodness gracious.
How the...
Oh, okay.
I died.
Uh-oh.
oh okay oh i died again wait how i'm causing a blockage wait i'm stuck okay there we go okay all right yeah yeah oh yeah all right just just make it over without dying well you go get that First, you go, yeah, keep going, keep, okay.
Noise.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, now it doesn't matter if I live or die or anything.
If I cry.
Live and let in.
Don't cry, don't cry.
I'm crying.
Okay, what's over here?
There's so much going on nowadays.
I know.
Wait, hold on.
Let me get up there.
Oops.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Okay, jump.
Okay, there you go.
Maybe move the thingy.
Yeah, I think I gotta get that thingy.
Okay.
You go get that thingy?
Okay, I'm getting the thingy.
Very good, very good.
Oh!
Okay.
What the heck?
Oh, oopsie.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Okay.
Ah, okay, okay.
Ow.
Okay, you go?
You go?
Oh, okay.
Go.
I'll go, go, go, go.
And then...
Oh.
Uh...
Oh, okay.
You don't know!
Thank you for the ring!
Thank you!
Thank you for the friend!
Right now we're dying.
Says you.
Wait, there's a secret.
Get off the thing!
Wait, not yet!
She's trying to kill me!
That was a mistake!
Alright, stay there, stay there.
Okay.
Wait, maybe not?
Wait, how do we...
Oh.
Maybe...
Come on, this one maybe?
Yeah.
Just run for it.
Yeah, just run for it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oops.
Oh.
Wait, we missed so much though.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean, maybe there's only five.
Maybe?
No, there's definitely more.
I think there was something that we missed.
It's fine.
We can't go back.
We can just go, yeah.
Nah, it's fine.
Whatever.
We're rich.
We're rich, man.
We don't need any more money.
There was something in, like, the top right, but that's okay.
Oh.
Did we get the ball?
Yeah, I got it.
That's when you tried to kill me.
Okay, I think it's fine.
Oh, we missed two.
Yeah, we missed two.
Oopsie.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
All right.
Wait, why was the...
the past one like so hard i don't know right they were like you play you were good at this game now oops why is there a boulder here though that's suspicious oops we have to bring a boulder oh my god i think we have to build bring the boulder don't i think we have to build don't make us do this
make us do this.
Oh, you have to time it with the...
Oh, yeah, I see.
You have to time it.
Why does it...
Why does it stinkin' roll like that?
It has no friction.
It has no fricks.
Gives no fricks either.
Okay, we gotta be fast, though.
Once I throw it, you gotta grab it.
Okay, okay.
Wait, it'll stop like that.
Okay, and then...
Grab it!
Ah!
Okay.
Once I make my move, you're free to grab the bow.
How would I grab it?
Oh, wait.
What is this accent?
I'm really bad at...
I'm like bad at any accent.
I'm so sorry.
You should not...
Don't laugh!
Save bottle...
Save bottle of water.
water with a british action whoa whoa okay so you can do that yeah whoa whoa whoa oh oh nice nice oh you almost got it sorry i think i blocked you yeah probably god
what the fuck oh you're so good at this game okay hold on let me bring this over Okay.
Oh, I'm a bad.
Hold on.
Okay.
You got it.
Oh, nice!
Okay.
What do I do with it now?
Now what?
How do we...
Is there another one over here?
Or do we have to bring this?
You might have to bring that, yeah.
Uh...
Oh, can you grab it from that side?
No.
I don't...
Is...
Did we have to bring...
Did we need to bring it at all?
Uh...
No, no, no, we definitely...
I think we...
Wait, hold on.
What if I throw it?
I'm going to throw it?
It might be...
It might waste all of our hard work, but I'm going to drop it.
Wait, okay, I'll be here.
I'll be here.
Oh, no, you made it!
You made it!
Okay, nice.
Wait, but what's this under here?
I have no clue.
Is that like a...
Oh, that's the thing that's...
That's the thing.
Oh, that's the timer.
Yeah, it's turning on the blocks on and off.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, you got it.
Okay, nice.
Wait, there's a ball up there.
Yeah, there's the ball of yarn.
Okay.
I know that block turns...
There we go.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, you...
Okay, let me see over there.
Yeah, you get ready to jump.
Okay, I'm ready to jump.
I'm ready to jump, babe!
Yeah!
Nice, nice, nice, perfect.
It was a celebratory death?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, on purpose, on purpose.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I died.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, it's okay.
Okay, I killed him.
You did it, you did it, though.
Okay.
And then...
Okay,
you have to...
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
This is the teamwork that people dream of.
Oh, there you go.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Uh, wait.
Oh, is this a timing thing, too?
No.
No, no, no.
I don't think we need to go a white one.
Yeah.
Good job.
Oh, yeah.
Uh, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
I can't see.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Oh, I can't see.
Oh, I made it.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
We're so good.
Oh, how do you do this?
I think you gotta go up, but then the spikes will get you.
But there's spikes.
But then...
How do you...
Oh wait, can you... can you... if you... if you throw?
Maybe?
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
You got it!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I just did exactly what she did.
Dang, that gun is... Oh.
Yeah, this is like one of the best items, I think.
Oh, you could have just let me, you know.
Okay.
Yeah.
How do you...
Oh, I have to float on that guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, you got this.
Oh, well, I still got it.
Yeah, you still... You just... You don't need to focus on the gym.
anymore yeah oh oops oops oops oh okay i'm not timing this well at all everybody you got it no you got it okay okay nice there you go and i have to do it your turn oh wait hold on i always time this time you wait for his little fat head and then you jump and then you jump and then okay easy peasy all right we're so bad oh we do it again yeah we do it again Whoa!
Wait, how?
The saws are so...
Wait, your turn.
Is it definitely...
Actually...
I don't know why I talked about this.
Actually, an insane...
What the...
Wait, how did you step on that?
What the heck?
I don't know!
My turn.
Actually, your plan was like, Way better, honestly.
Like, shoot the guns.
Okay, okay.
And then we only have to time him when he's over on the other side.
Okay.
Like...
Oh, well, I missed.
Oh, so close.
Dude, those claws are so insane.
You think this is gonna give out?
Oh, no!
Ah, no!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
You got it, you got it.
Oh, nice, you got it!
I got it!
You can make it!
Oh, I did!
Yeah!
Wait, your turn.
No, it's just like the way you set it in the punch really got me.
Oh my goodness gracious.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna die!
Ah!
No, no!
Okay, don't die!
Oh,
okay.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Oops.
Oh, cool.
Thank you.
Okay.
What is this?
Oh, you go the other way, I think.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Okay,
that wasn't on me.
That wasn't on me.
Okay, I thought you were pressing the button, not...
No, no!
Okay, now you go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
Oh, no, what the heck?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay, just don't stop pressing the button.
Maybe sometimes, stop pressing the button.
Actually, how do we get in here?
Is this the secret here?
No.
I think it's, like, over...
Over...
Maybe...
Wait.
Oh, I think it's in that hole.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
Am I...
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Alright.
You're so stupid!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
No, I want the jetpack back.
We don't need the jetpack.
I do.
Oh wait.
Maybe we do need the jetpack.
No, we don't need the jetpack.
Oh, I keep dying anyway.
Oh, you got it already?
Okay.
Yeah, I got it.
We don't need the jetpack.
Why did I do that?
Oh wait.
We need to go over there.
Go.
You got...
Okay, one more try.
One more time.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Go.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, we're killing it.
We're killing it and each other.
We're doing it.
Uh...
Ooh!
Wow.
Oh, that's tough.
Okay, there's a jewel over there.
Oh.
Okay.
I took it for you.
I tanked it for you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, shit.
Can't swim.
Wait, where did it put... Oh, yeah.
Hello?
It...
Okay.
Team!
Is my team cooked?
The kids might call us chopped.
No, shh!
Chat, am I chopped?
Chat, are we cooked?
We got it.
Okay.
Oh, you got it?
Yeah, I got it.
I got it.
Yippee!
You're fine.
Cooked, chopped, washed.
It's over.
No, I'm not chopped.
We're all sorts of adjectives you wouldn't even imagine, man.
Flambade.
Oh, I made it.
Things must be chopped and cooked before they can be eaten and served.
That's true.
I'm always serving.
Why did it put me down up there?
Okay, thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, wait, this is messed up.
How?
I literally made it.
Wait, oh, there's the...
There's a...
Yeah.
I see it.
I got it.
I don't got it.
You got it.
I don't Oh, okay, over there Nice, she's gaming I don't know how you get the ball though How do you get the ball?
Oh, there's also one up here Oh, no!
You're drowning It's okay Get it, get it, get it!
Get it!
Wait, why aren't you?
See, it happened to me too!
It happened to me too!
It's tough, it's tough.
Alright.
Guys, don't say...
We just want a B for Barry, okay?
B for Barry Bog.
B for everyone.
F for...
What is it for?
Phantom!
Yeah, Phantom!
Oh!
I didn't know what you were doing.
I was like, why are you posing like that?
I was just aura farming.
Oh my gosh!
I can't do the double job!
There you go.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Uh.
I don't think...
Oh wait, I got it!
Okay, okay, you jump?
Oh, or not.
Whatever.
Do it properly.
Oh wait, do it properly.
Ah!
Oh shit.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh, she made it!
I made it.
Oh shit.
Send me over.
No, no, no, you're supposed, I think you're supposed to, like, you know, the...
Like the...
Yeah, yeah, time it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just gotta be good at it.
You just gotta be good.
You just gotta do it.
You just gotta be good at it.
You just gotta be...
Wait, hold on.
Okay.
Wait.
Wait, it's tough!
Okay, chief.
Oh!
Not anything else!
Okay, okay, I got it.
I die!
Hey, hey, hey.
Do it properly.
Okay.
Wait.
Do it properly.
Wait, how am I supposed to jump up there?
Hey.
I've tried.
Lisa.
I can't jump any higher.
Sir, I actually cannot jump the appropriate amount to be able to continue.
Okay, I'm going to die now.
All right.
Wait!
Do it properly.
Wait, how did you get up there?
Double jump.
I did too.
I don't think you did it well.
That's what I...
Man, he's bull.
Oh, like that.
I'm begging you.
Mint.
Fireball.
Okay, I think I...
I got the jewels.
You done?
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, no, no.
On your side, there's one.
There is?
Okay.
You got it.
Yeah, you got it.
You got that, right?
Oh, oh, no you don't.
Oh, that's evil.
That's evil.
Maybe you need me to do that.
I don't need nobody in my afterlife.
Why are you killing me?
This is why I don't need anybody.
Because all they do is disappoint you.
What do you mean?
Someone's not a team player.
Okay.
Alright, okay.
I think I throw you over.
Okay.
No!
Oops.
How do you do that?
Hello.
Oh, maybe I don't jump.
Maybe...
Like, we gotta get closer, yeah.
Yeah, maybe you have to be at the edge.
Oh, why is...
I'm holding right trigger.
Why am I not?
Okay.
Ah!
Throw me!
Oh, that wasn't...
Oh, sorry.
That wasn't...
No, I think it was me.
I didn't have enough free.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Here, I'll throw you.
Okay, okay.
Ah!
Oh!
We got it!
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Let's get out of this hellhole.
Oh!
Oh my, oh my, oh my, oh my goodness gracious.
Oh my goodness gracious indeed!
Oh, come on, it's always the spikes.
No.
Oopsie.
Please!
I want to go home.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Face off, please.
Oh, wait, there's no Okay, we're good.
I want to go home.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, how do we do this?
Oh, it's a puzzle.
Oh, wait, you go that way.
Okay, nice.
All right.
Now, hold on.
hold on hold on oh okay oh nice nice okay and then and then oh god oh god like this and then wait yeah wait okay then oh uh oh oh okay can you push it forward no you can't no okay hold on okay hold on okay hold on wait wait wait wait we just go oh wait no hold on uh hold on okay hold on Uh...
Hold on.
Okay, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, hold on.
Wait.
I can't tell if it's a spammer or...
I can't tell if there's people spamming in my chat or...
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Eh, who's spamming?
I can't tell if it's a...
Oh!
Liz, thank you for the break!
We have war crying!
Ah!
I'm sorry I didn't see a red thank you hi readers hi I was like wait do not do your British accent
don't wait I think you just trapped us no no no no and then we reset we we we okay wait I did trap us you just trapped us wait no no no no no no no Okay.
We're playing...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, and then you push it.
Oh, you're so smart!
You're so smart!
Okay, bye.
Yeah, we're playing Battle Block Theater right now.
Yeah, this game is so fun!
You should play it with somebody too, or...
Ah!
Oh.
Wait, okay, jump off of me.
Or I jump off of you.
Okay.
There you go.
Okay, I jumped.
Okay.
I don't see that every day.
Oh!
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
One more time.
This one's for you, Liz.
Okay.
Yeah.
I got you.
You might...
Yeah, okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, we got everything.
Oh, oopsie.
Okay.
Nice first try, yeah.
Yeah, first try.
First try, first try.
Good job.
Oh.
I...
Why would it put me there?
Why
would it put me there?
We did it!
Yippee!
Oh my goodness, yeah, first try, first try.
Thank you guys for all the gifts, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Wait, do you kill?
Do you kill, right?
Yeah, kill.
Oh, that wasn't kill.
Stop.
Wait.
I went up one too far many.
Oh, they're all here?
Okay, okay.
I'm okay.
Everything's fine.
Yep.
Everything's okay.
Everything's A-OK.
Okay.
I'm going.
I turned off something.
I'm still going.
Okay.
I'm going.
Okay, wake up the Kappa.
How do you, okay, okay.
Oh, wait, am I going the right way?
I think we were supposed to follow him.
Maybe.
Oh.
Oh my God, this is gracious.
Help!
Okay.
Help, wait, hold on.
Oh.
Like that, maybe?
What?
Oh, he's dead.
Where?
Oh, wait, oh, we're supposed to like ride on top of...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Because he's supposed to like step on the thing?
Oh, yeah, he does.
Or what's going on here?
No, he just...
He dies after a while, I think.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, oh, oh, goodbye.
How am I supposed to get on top of him?
I don't know.
Ah!
Okay, maybe let's not just go that way.
I think it's fine.
I don't think there's any other way to go.
Any other way to go?
Here, I'm gonna keep trying.
You try down there.
I try up here.
Okay.
Fireball.
I think I need you.
No, I need you.
I need you.
Mint, I need you.
Oh, okay.
I need you.
You need me to throw you?
Lock the hook in.
No, can you press on the button?
Oh, okay.
Oops.
Ah!
I wasn't ready!
Okay.
One more?
Yeah, one more.
Nice.
Very good.
Okay, there we go.
Yep.
Is it?
Or maybe we should...
Okay.
I think it's...
I think this is the right idea.
We just gotta...
I have no idea.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
Well, maybe, maybe it's not, maybe we don't use him.
I think we do.
Hold on.
Did so?
Oh!
But, but, but how do you, yeah, how do you get past the- Yeah, he dies.
There's no way.
Yeah, he's- oh, oh, he stops there.
Yeah, but then he dies.
What the?
Wow.
Is that you?
Ah!
Yeah, that was me.
Oh, okay.
Oh, sorry.
Go.
Oh, he's...
Okay, there we go.
Go.
Whoa.
Hello?
Don't move.
Just wait it out.
See what happens.
Oh, he does die.
What the?
What are we supposed to do then?
Yeah, he stops at the stop side.
I think I'm supposed to jump.
Or maybe we're supposed to both make it through?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Oh, sorry.
Wait.
Wait, hold on.
I have no idea.
He dies from the sign.
Yeah, but like...
Eh?
Eh.
Huh?
What?
Oh, he turns around and he eats you and shoots you!
Oh my god, right!
Okay, okay.
Oh my god!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Why didn't he turn around any other time?
I don't know.
He just decides to show us his booty.
All of a sudden he wants to turn around.
I think that probably...
There you go, yeah.
Go on up.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Jam, jam.
Oh god oh god oh god oh god.
Okay yeah.
We're fine.
Okay.
What is that?
I'm trying to get there but...
Oh that probably that probably when you go to the bottom it like probably sends you to the- Oh!
Probably like a loop.
Oh.
Oh you are?
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck!
No, you're not.
Oh, wait.
I have to DC my controller.
Hold on.
Oh, okay.
Hello?
Uh-oh.
Curse game.
What happened?
Barry!
I-I'm trying to control my controller, but...
You're unable to join the match.
Could not connect to all players?
Huh?
You're right here in front of me.
I know, I see you.
You're moving around right now.
Yeah, I am.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe I can...
How do I...
Uh...
What?
Why doesn't my controller work?
Let me re-plug.
Yeah.
Mint, I think you'll have to finish it without me.
I can't!
I literally cannot!
You have to believe.
If you believe, you can finish it.
ship without me i don't think i can i i actually i don't know if i can yeah i don't know it's it says i i i'm unable to join the match but i see you moving around on my screen so i don't know why i can't like what what are you like huh wait
actually this way Dang it.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Okay.
What the heck?
Yeah, it's...
I'm trying to use my keyboard and it's not even letting me play on my keyboard.
Wait.
We're done.
No!
Wait, what?
Don't die on me.
Oh, where'd you go?
I...
Oh, I think you're gone now!
No, wait.
Okay, I'm...
No, I'm going to respawn.
I, I, okay, let me come back.
I'm joining.
I'm coming.
You need me to send you an invite?
Oh, all players have left again.
No, I just joined off of you.
Huh?
Oh my god.
What?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, you're gone.
You're gone.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm coming.
I'm coming back online.
No, you're gone.
You're gone.
It says I can't complete.
Why is my controller just not working?
I do this every time.
Okay, I quit the game.
Let me send you an invite.
Oh, wait.
No, my controller's not working anymore now.
What the heck?
Hold on, I gotta use my other controller.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Please hold.
We're so close to the end.
I know.
It's not because of the Wi-Fi, you guys.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Okay, good.
My spy controller stopped working for a second.
It's a first.
oh my god it like just killed my entire like controller setup i don't know oh my god i also then i press then i invite wait it says you're not online anymore let me see if i can uh it says you're not online anymore berry i it killed me oh no i'm i'm i'm online now wait hold on oh i'm just usually offline hold on uh wait are you hosting i can just join join your game uh yeah i did okay there you go okay let me let me uh okay time for keyboard mouse
okay wait sorry sorry sorry i was just messaging because uh we're nearing oh yeah i have but it's okay i asked if if maybe they're free a little bit later later we're okay are you sure yeah if they say no then we can end early but or end at the time but if they say it's okay then we can we can continue okay we're so close we are oh i just realized you're it's working for you now yeah okay all right they said no problem okay let's go Okay.
All right, we're going to finish Battle Block and then we're going to make out and then we're going to eat jellies.
I thought I was getting Thai food.
Oh, that's right.
Why are you saying it with an accent?
Because you don't like my accent?
I want to hear your best British accent.
All right, what should I say?
Say, do you want T.F.
Crumpets in the morning?
Do you want Tay and Crump?
It's in the morning.
Crump.
Every accent I try to do always turns into something southern.
I know.
I noticed that.
Every, every.
Every.
T-T-T-T and cramp.
You just gotta play it up like stupid, you know?
Oh, I did it again.
Oops, I did it again.
Oh my god, they launched me.
Wait, how did you do this before?
Just the second from the top, I think, maybe?
Or maybe not even that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like that.
And then I just...
Oh, just don't get caught.
All right.
Yeah, don't get caught.
I love...
I...
What are you trying to say?
I love...
I love Doctor Who.
Oh, I love...
I love...
I love me...
I love Doctor Who.
I can't...
I can't listen to this anymore.
I'm taking on my damn headphones.
Oh god, we have to do this nightmare again.
I know, it's okay though, we know now.
Why doesn't he...
Wait, you got...
Can we help me do this first?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, come back!
Come back!
Actually, yeah, go?
There you go.
Oh my...
It's like so much easier once you understand what it wants from you.
This asshole...
Okay, whatever.
For real.
I'm over it.
Oh wait, wait, can I just click on...
Can I just have...
Oh wait, wait!
Come back, come back up.
Oh, okay, I'll do it.
Yeah.
There you go.
Yeah, nice, nice, nice, nice.
And I won't die.
Yeah!
We got it.
I'm traumatized by this part now.
Okay, we're good, we're good.
Nice.
And now what?
Oh, wait, I stopped here.
You jump, you jump.
I'm jumping, I'm jumping.
Oh, you got it.
I set it off.
What does that do?
There's a boulder.
Now I think we can teleport.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, the boulder was blocking.
Oh.
The boulder was blocking it.
He's unleashing frogs!
Oh, yeah, I guess that's all of it.
Oops.
You got it?
Nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh God.
Oh, I see.
Oh, God.
Wait, we need the ball.
We need the ball of yarn.
Where is it?
How do we get the...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Nice, nice.
I didn't kill him, but...
Hold on.
Oops.
Oh, oh, sorry, sorry.
Okay, go.
Oops.
Okay, nope.
I'm trying.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Do your best.
Hold on.
I'll kill him.
I'll kill him with my bare hands.
Kill him.
Just kill him.
Oops.
I'll kill him.
oops hold on you got him you got him oh oh oh hold on oh oh i'm dying again oh it's okay it's okay oh my god i tried to dodge it and i don't know what i was thinking okay oh my god okay okay okay it's okay it's okay it's okay hold on oh oh yeah put a little thing there put a little thing there oh okay yeah okay there you go does that help yeah if i could get a okay Okay.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I can't do it.
I can't do it, Barry.
Hold on.
Wait.
Do you have another range?
I can't do it.
I can't do it, Barry.
Hold on.
Wait.
Do you have another range?
Wait, I have other ranged weapons.
Hold on.
Oh, I got him.
Okay.
Maybe?
Oh, you did?
I, like, somehow... Somehow did...
Oh, wait, look!
Hurry!
Run!
I accidentally stepped on the thing!
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Oops.
Oh, no.
Wait, I don't know if you can make it.
Oh, if I wall jumped, I would be able to.
No, no, no, it's okay.
That was my fault.
It's okay!
It's all good!
We missed one anyway.
gracious
Don't mind me, everything okay?
Yep, don't mind me Excuse me, uh, excuse me Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Don't mind me Okay, come Okay, oh, oh, oh, okay, nice Thank you You're welcome.
And...
Thank you.
Any secrets though?
Nope, I guess not.
Oh, there's a teleport.
Oh, wait, wait!
Okay.
Oh, I screwed that up.
It's okay.
I'm such a big old screw up.
Don't say that!
Do we have to...
What do we do?
There's Boulder.
Oh, I see.
There's...
Oh, there's a, we have to get it up here.
No!
Oh my god.
One puzzle only.
Okay.
How do we...
Hold on.
Maybe like this, and then...
What?
Ah, freak!
What did it do?
Oh, my bad.
Thank you.
No, I'm freak!
Okay.
I think, I think, oh, okay.
Oh, I see what's your boy here you're trying to do.
Oh, okay.
That works, too.
You, um, it's because it's gonna fall off unless you stop.
Oh, you stopped it.
Okay.
Oops.
You're so good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Ah, wait, let me change my weapon back.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
I'm fine.
Okay, there you go.
Oops.
Whoa, my god.
Get this guy out of here, man.
Get this guy out of here.
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, oh, there's the emerald.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, you got it.
All right, nice.
Are there any secrets though?
We'll never know.
Oops.
What happened?
I don't know.
They just...
Wait, what did I do?
The button...
Oh, it's on the button.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Oops.
Ah!
Okay.
Be careful.
All right.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
We got it though.
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Died in the process, but it's all part of the plan.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's all worth it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oops.
I think, I think we got...
Oh.
Just go!
Okay, let's go!
Let's go!
Do we miss anything?
Is that it?
Four?
I think we missed some stuff.
I think we might have missed.
I don't... I didn't... Oh.
Oh, wow.
We missed two.
Two.
That's fun.
We're fine.
B for Bantone.
Shame on Harry Hattigton.
Shame on you!
Shame!
All right.
Oh my, oh, they're booing him.
Wow.
Are they?
Yeah, yeah, they're booing him.
You cannot walk, for this is a race against the clock.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, here we go.
Good start.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
When the screen gets so small, it's so hard to tell.
Oh.
Ah!
It's okay.
Or it's okay for me.
Yeah.
Well, you made it.
It's cool.
It's okay.
I don't want to live anywhere.
Ouch.
Hold on.
Let me use your head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Use my head.
Use my noggin.
Oh, it will.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
There we go.
There you go.
what?
Why can't I okay?
Okay.
Hello.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Nice?
Okay.
Nice.
You're so good at this game.
Ditto gaming?
I can't see anything anymore.
Okay.
Oh, you got something up there?
Oh, why am I all the way back here?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, just...
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Why?
What are these weird spawns?
It's because of that guy blowing us up.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, okay.
Oh my god.
How did you actually get past him?
Oh, there we go.
That works.
Wait, hold on.
Can you push me up there?
Or...
Wait, uh...
Oh my god.
No!
Oh, there we go.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Oh my god!
Ah, bitch!
I hate this guy, man.
I know, they're so annoying.
Okay.
Can you jump?
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Over here.
Oh, here, I'll kill him.
Okay.
Can you come over here?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Just bounce, bounce, bounce.
There we go.
Yeah!
Okay, okay, we're good.
Oh, what do we need?
Get in the paper boat.
Maybe?
What?
Oh, yeah.
Maybe?
Oh, you have to use it.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
What?
You have to use it to get into the teleporter.
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, we're about to run out of time.
We're about to run out of time.
Oh, uh-uh.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
Okay.
Now jump into a...
Yeah, there we go.
Oh, nice!
Wait, no, that just...
What?
Oh, my God!
That is nothing!
It's so misleading!
What?
The boat was for the yarn?
Oh, what the heck?
I guess that makes a little bit of sense, maybe.
Oh, oopsie.
Yeah, that's...
That's weird.
Jump on my head and then jump from there maybe?
Yep.
There you go.
Okay, nice.
Oh, you got it?
Nice.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Just keep going, just keep going.
Uh, oh, thank you.
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, ouch.
But it's okay.
We're cool.
You got it.
We got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't.
Tiny screen.
Green, okay.
Oh, oops, not bad.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Oh, damn it.
Okay, move the boat to the bottom.
I'll wait if I could.
I'll handle him.
Okay, okay.
Okay, go.
I thought I would.
Well, um...
Okay, it's okay.
Just get the...
Go get the yarn.
Go get the yarn!
Oh, what?
Oh, my God.
Did you get it?
No.
Oh.
Ah.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I got it.
Oh, nice.
Okay, nice.
And I exploded.
Okay.
And then we just go down here.
Yep.
And then...
Uh, we go here.
Oh!
Ow!
Wait, how the heck are we supposed to do this fire?
Oh, because of the...
Oh, I guess...
Oh, that's a weird time.
Yeah.
It's weird timing.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, okay.
It's like just barely enough time to push you down.
What?
You have to like swoop under it.
Yeah, that feels so exact.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Good timing.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
Ah!
This is gonna be...
That can't be it, is it?
Oh!
You're supposed to use...
Yeah, okay, okay.
That makes sense.
The timing?
We both did it?
Okay.
Oh my god.
At least we know what we know now.
We know now.
Oh my god.
I feel like the last few levels like jumped in difficulty so much.
I know, like crazy.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, what the heck?
Okay, good job, good job.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
That's okay.
You got it?
Okay, nice.
Yep, yep, yep.
We're freaking gaming.
We're gaming, yeah.
Gaming?
Okay, nice.
Oh, I forgot.
Okay, you got it.
I'll take our...
Okay, okay, go.
I'm putting it down.
Okay.
Go.
I got it.
Yeah, okay, nice.
oh okay okay oh gosh oh gosh okay now we know what to do yeah go go go go go go go go go go go go oh well maybe not then oh my gosh oh my god oh my god i think i messed you up it's okay at a time.
Nice!
They're so good!
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
Oh, oh my God.
Oh my God.
Okay, just ignore that.
It's okay.
Okay.
Owey.
I don't know what I hit.
Oh, there's a saw.
Oh.
Oh, he has to duck at the bend.
okay oh nice nice nice i was like where are we ducking i don't know i'll let you do it man stop it stop it stop it you yeah good job good job okay nice got another kick his ass get his ass uh okay oh ow oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh oopsie no ice nice kick his ass oh just kidding oh man oh sorry that was me it's okay it's okay you're supposed to use the the lava at the side to to get on i'm trying or or i guess you could do that uh oh there's a there's a teleportation
uh you'll see maybe if i can oh there you go now oh oh nice oh you just have to keep holding you just have to keep okay oh my god
are you okay you have to fight don't worry about it okay not that wait is this okay oh ouch ouch okay hold on to the top yeah yep yep oh but how do we maybe i hold on do i press this button go check oh maybe sorry there's also oh I don't know if we're supposed to be over here.
Wait.
You think so?
Oops.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
This is a nightmare.
Oh, you got it.
You got it.
Okay.
But how do we...
How do we...
I mean, we can't go back up.
Oh, oh, the boulder.
What does the boulder do, though?
For what?
There's a thing at the end.
There's a cloud at the end.
Oh, oh, that's right, that's right, the cloud!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Don't go underneath.
Here, I'll just send this in too.
Oh my, oh my, oh my god.
Ow!
Oh my god, oh my god.
This is a nightmare!
What?
What is this?
Oh my gosh.
Oops, oops.
Oh my god.
What the heck?
You sucker.
Oh, I see what you meant about the...
Oops.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did you grab that or no?
Oh, my gosh.
I did, I did.
Okay.
Idiot, you hit yourself.
Yeah.
Oh, please, please, please, please.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Ah, I was trapped in a loop!
Ah!
Who is?!
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, I'll go.
How do we do it this time?
Because that doesn't make anything disappear.
I guess it's just the boulder.
Yeah, we just gotta do the boulder.
Like, use it to, like, stand, you know, like, like this.
Yeah.
Oops, my bad.
Oh god.
Uh-oh, now we have to grab him again.
Okay.
Wait!
You could get the, what's it called if you want?
because uh oh shoot oh right okay hold on i threw it i threw it i threw it nice you did it you did it okay you just have to push that you just have to push that okay nice i got it oh i don't got it you got it uh try just holding the grab button so that you could yeah yeah yeah okay nice i got it nice okay let's go oh my gosh oh my god oh my god check point check point okay oh my god I can't do another one of these,
Barry.
I can't do it anymore.
I can't do this shit anymore.
I'm like, wait, what?
What are we supposed to do here?
Did you grab the yarn or no?
Yeah, I did, I did.
Oh, nice.
What the hell are we supposed to do?
I think we're supposed to, like, fall onto the...
onto the pink stuff, the goo.
Oh, the goo makes sense.
Wait, does it make sense?
Oh, we're gonna lose...
How the hell?
Oh?
Wait, that's crazy.
What?
What do we do there?
This is tough.
Wait, there's another one on the left side.
Yeah, try and grab it.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Can I move?
You got it.
I'm just going to die.
I'm going to just die.
Don't die.
Believe in yourself.
Okay, I'm going.
Okay.
I don't think the button does anything.
Golders?
Oh, oops.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, sorry.
Okay, one at a time.
Here we go.
Oh!
Oh, you got it!
You got it!
Oh, my gosh.
I got it, I got it!
You got it, you got it.
Okay, now this is our next hurdle.
I do want a follow yarn, though.
Oh, yeah.
You can keep trying.
I'll try to figure this out or something.
Okay, okay.
Or I'll try and get the yarn.
You're better at wall jumping than I am.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got it.
I got the yarn.
Okay.
Nice, instantly.
Okay, okay.
But how do you do you do this, man?
How do you do this?
I have no idea.
Because you can't really double jump.
Maybe.
Okay, I guess you're...
See,
there's like no place for you to like catch your...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on.
Oh.
I'm not even going to try, guys.
Sorry.
Okay, it's okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
Go, go, Minto!
Go!
We're so close!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, wait, what?
Almost there, almost there, almost there.
Ah!
Oh my god!
These are messed up, man.
These are messed up.
Oh my goodness.
I can only do it because you- Because you are here too.
Oh, is that true?
Oh my, the staff is really upset now.
The lack of proper leadership has really twisted their fanny cheeks.
Hard.
Where's the appreciation?
Where's the sparkly money's at?
Oh yeah.
Good one, bro.
And as you continue to conjure magic to distract the masses your efforts seem in vain as your constant struggle to save hatty and your friends has only created grander spectacles with harder obstacles yeah how's that for a double-edged sword sharp right and the audience loves it the applause is deafening the sandpapery kisses are plentiful and tickly and they always want more more bigger harder that's what she's i mean uh this place is turning into quite the impressive palace of horror now i mean you're gonna be up to your throat and cats and lasers like
and bombs and explosions like bang bang bang bang so i'd stay on your toes if i were you bang because it's gonna be a massacre a fun house of death except twice no three times as deadly it's already a massacre this little predicament cake of yours the staff is sick of had his bulls beat uh nonsense they're sick of him look how upset they are gaze in horror at the disorderly disorder It's chaos!
It's...
You should be.
Bang!
This is chat right now.
No!
It's terrible.
Everyone's naked and rioting and pooping on the floor.
No!
Clawing the expensive curtains.
Come on, guys.
They're expensive.
Everything is going up in a horrifying blaze of chaos.
Plus, the picnic was cancelled and I've kind of got a little headache coming on.
It just never ends.
But go forth and give it your all.
I won't believe it.
you fought and died for nothing and perhaps when it's all over I'll meet you in the afterlife whilst perusing the hall of heroes where the brave live forever there's also a hall of losers and failures you don't want to end up there trust me it's embarrassing wait there's more there has to be oh maybe the final boss yeah this is the finale oh my god Oh,
what happened?
Chapter 7.
Wait.
Wait, so there is...
I think people were right.
There are eight chapters.
Are there eight chapters?
Uh-uh.
Oh, my goodness.
We gotta lock in.
Yeah.
Wait, how many are?
Let's see.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you already went?
That's okay.
Yeah, I already went in.
I think it's the same amount as usual, anyway.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
Gems of three will set you free.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
We just gotta lock in.
We don't have to...
Oh my... Wait, look at that!
Look at that!
I want it.
Um...
Okay.
Just use my head, yeah!
Uh, let's see.
What?
Okay.
And...
Oh my god, everything is... Ow!
Nice.
Okay.
Not one.
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, ow.
Oh, pfft.
Double kill.
Oh, I'm fine
now.
But we definitely...
Oh, oh, oh, there we
go.
It's okay.
Yeah, put it to that.
Oh, okay.
It's
in a loop now.
Oh, it's in a loop, too.
We're good.
Okay.
Oh, God.
I'm sorry.
Maybe I'll just leave it to you.
I'll just leave it to you.
I'm trying.
Oh, my God.
How
do I get back to you?
Uh-oh.
I don't think I can get back to you.
Oh, you did it!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
It's okay, it's okay.
Okay.
What is that news for?
A bunch of stuff.
Oh, wait, no, we needed to...
Oh, wait, no, I messed up the boat.
Oh, reset.
It's okay.
No, it's okay.
Where am I?
You're down in the bottom.
I'm like...
I don't think I can do anything up here.
Yeah, I think you should try... Oh, hello.
Hello.
Oh, I don't know what to do here though.
Oh, we need another boulder, I guess.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, fuck.
Get on my head.
Ah, the timing!
The timing.
Okay.
Oh, why am I down here?
Get on my head.
Thank you.
Your sacrifice would not be forgotten yeah this way yeah it's oh i can throw oh no i was gonna say i could throw you but there's the wall yeah oh well oh well meaning oh my goodness how do we but are we are okay oh we are okay oh it killed him and then yeah and then it's already put in the water below yeah Or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Uh...
Bullet.
Yep.
Yep, yep, yep.
Okay.
And then...
There's an alien.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
There's also a robot.
There's a great alien and a robot.
There's...
There's so many.
Uh...
Or...
What is...
What is this?
Oh, a boulder!
Yeah, there's a boulder for something.
Yeah.
Uh, for what, though?
I think maybe we have to take it upstairs.
Or somehow.
Maybe?
There was.
Or we take it to the teleport?
Do we have to take it up?
There was another place for a thing.
I just don't know how to get it up there.
Uh.
Maybe we put it in here.
Maybe we teleported through here.
I'm not sure how, though.
I was thinking maybe we use the...
Like this thing?
Throw it?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Okay, nice, nice, yeah.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Awesome, awesome.
Okay, now let's go this way.
Okay, what does this do?
Ah!
Uh, okay.
I think I keep it like that, I'm stuck.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, and I go right here?
Oh, hello.
Oh, why?
You're all the way back at the top.
Whoa, why?
Uh, well, I don't know.
But you can get back to the boulder now.
See there, there.
Yeah, and you can put it in.
God damn it!
What the heck?
The boulder killed you.
Why did I why did I?
I would help you, but I can't do it.
Yeah, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Where am I?
Oh, you're by the boulder.
okay okay now i think i'm good okay okay oh my gosh apparently you need a third boulder oh there's a third boulder above you above me oh yeah i see it i see it okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay oh my god um he's like spawn camping me oh oh oh no where did it put me why yeah i don't know it like Oh,
ok, ok, ok, ok.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, okay.
Alright.
And it should be there, okay.
Wait, no, you have to, yeah, you have to be there.
Yeah, go.
Okay.
And then...
Okay
Nice.
Okay.
Nice!
Yeah!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
All right.
There's no ball.
Wait, did we get the ball or there was none?
No, it was trapped.
Oh, that's right.
It was the...
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
You should be cursing me out, Minto.
Screw you, Barrybug.
I'm really serious about this game.
And I'm upset.
Barrybug lives on 123 Main Street.
Fairy bug lives One, two, three In my walls In my walls Get it, get it, there you go Thank you The exit's over Where do I go from here?
Where, where, yeah Where, I'm going Wait, there's a portal right here Okay, here But I can't reach anything I'm trapped Oh no Okay I'm teaching to you.
Okay, hello.
Hello.
Okay.
Okay, I can throw you into the portal.
Maybe.
Oh, maybe not.
Sorry.
Wait, I think it's going to send me here.
Do you think so?
Oh, my gosh.
Am I just double jumping poorly?
How about that?
There you go.
Oh, yeah.
I guess I can go here.
Ah!
Go where?
Oh my god!
Oh no, is that where we came from?
Is that where we came from?
We need to figure out a way to...
Oh.
I'm trying to get up here.
There we go.
Thank you.
There you go.
Oh, that was a close one.
Oh!
Can I just run?
Run.
You got it?
Yep.
Okay, nice.
I guess up here we break in.
What is this?
But...
Yeah.
Oh, you want to go up?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
Oh, get the boat.
Yeah, get the boat.
But then we have like a...
Oh!
Oh, oh, we have to...
Hold on.
Let me beat...
Let me beat you this one.
Oh, yeah!
We gotta turn off the fan.
And then...
That'll...
Oh my god.
It's taking a sweet-ass time.
And boom.
And then do that.
Oh, okay.
Whoa, that opened up everything in the world.
Okay.
And then...
Did that turn off?
Oh, we're back here.
Huh?
Howie.
Oh, oops.
I feel it.
We need the little guys, the pink guys.
Yeah, we definitely need them to get...
Oh, oopsie.
That's what I was trying to do earlier was like...
Yeah, yeah.
But maybe not.
No, I think you're...
I think it's right.
Really?
Yeah.
It's just hard to attempt.
I don't have to put...
Hold on, hold on.
Okay, okay.
Yeah!
There you go.
See?
Yeah, you got it.
You got it.
No!
It's fine.
I got him up here.
Yeah, you got it ready.
You got it ready.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Okay.
Yeah!
In here.
In there?
No.
Oops.
Okay.
Oh, my bad.
And then, I don't know how you would come over here.
My pig is invincible.
Wait, okay.
I somehow...
Um...
I think I can't make it.
Did...
Oh, wait.
Leave your guy over there and then do the help thing and then my pig will come over.
I made it.
Oh, wait.
No, it works out.
It worked out.
Yeah.
Wait, what am I supposed to do here, though?
Oh, I go...
And then you...
Yeah, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, again, whatever.
Okay.
Well, what is this to do?
Ah!
What is this to do?
Um...
It makes it so...
We can run.
Oh, yeah, I think we gotta do the thing where you, like, push me over again, you know?
You think so?
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Oh, I didn't get enough momentum, my bad.
Okay, ready?
Wait!
No, I don't...
Oh, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's supposed to be...
We put it here.
And then you...
How would you...
How would you do that?
Do you do it by yourself?
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
I turned it off on accident though.
You got it!
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're just supposed to run.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, okay.
But now what?
Where's the exit?
The ball of yarn is over there too is the thing.
The exit's right over there.
Like, once we get sent here.
Oh, I see.
Oh, but the ball of yarn.
But the ball of yarn.
Ew.
Ew, what the...
Was it always making that noise?
Ew.
I don't know.
I thought that was you for a second.
I was like, whoa.
Are you eating?
It's horrible.
Okay, I think we should...
We could just end it.
Okay.
The shlop, shlop, shlop.
It's so horrible.
Oh my god.
That was terrible.
It was so bad.
Oh.
I'm trying to get hungry though, Barry.
I want dinner soon.
Alright, we could probably do this level and then wrap up.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get tied.
It might take a while on the last few levels.
I know.
I'm feeling like Like, how, did we gaslight ourselves into thinking there was less than there actually was?
No, we're like, I think it's just we didn't expect how hard it would be.
We didn't expect it to be, like, so, so difficult.
Yeah, it, like, really ramped up.
I know, it did ramp up like crazy.
Oh, wait.
Jesus.
Oh, goodbye?
Hello?
Hi.
I don't know how I got here.
Uh, okay.
Yay!
Oh, okay.
Oh, that.
Oh, oopsie.
Jesus, it's okay.
But I don't know, how would you get over there?
Wait, how did you press the right trigger?
Hmm.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's me, I'm screwing up.
No, no, no, you're fine, you're fine.
Maybe you go on the ladder.
Oh, no, you got it, you got it.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh.
Holy moly.
Okay.
I gotta wait for him to...
Look at him.
Okay.
Well, there's no button!
I know, I don't know.
I don't know what you're supposed to do.
Oh, oh, oopsie.
Let me use your body.
Yeah, use my body.
Use my body.
There's so many things.
Okay, but how do you get all the...
I guess you have to...
At some point, they'll, like, let you go back and...
Do you have a level?
Wait, what?
No, we missed the button!
We missed a button?
Yeah, it's at the beginning, I guess?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, oh.
No, no, no, no, no, we have to just get through this.
And then I think the button's at the end.
Oh, my God, it's ice.
No, you go, oh, my God, wait, you're such a gamer.
Yeah, and then you go...
I gave it!
Oh, my God, what is this?
First try?
Try first try.
Uh-oh.
Oh, and then...
Oh, okay.
And then we do it again!
Without the boxes this time.
Yeah, without the box.
Oh, my bad.
I was not prepared.
Oh, I was sorry.
Here, you go.
You go.
It's okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
There you go.
You were eating that.
You were eating that for real.
Oh, my God.
Holy moly.
I think you can get in there, yeah.
There you go.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Why is my right trigger acting up?
Oh, it's fine.
Uh-oh.
Oh, that explains all the...
That explains why that...
There is that.
It's like temporary stuff, guys.
Oh, Minto!
Oops.
Not bad.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
Get on my head.
Nice, nice.
There we go.
Okay.
Is there a secret over there though?
Wait, because there's a ladder up there.
What on, send me over?
Oh, I don't think so.
Never mind, never mind, never mind.
Don't worry about it.
Hannah, you're me!
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you so much for the raid.
Hi, Hannah.
Thank you for the bait!
Let me read the...
There you go!
Nice.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, nice!
Wait, where was it?
Oh, here.
Yeah, the teleporter?
Okay, there we go.
Oh!
Oh, it shot me too.
Okay, that's cool.
Oops.
That's a new one.
You're good.
Oh my god!
I'm going insane!
I am.
I'm going insane mode.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Yeah, oh!
There was a secret in there.
Oh, me too.
Yeah, this game's old.
Wait, oh, I've mixed up my character with yours.
Yeah, it's pretty easy.
Sorry.
Good?
Bam!
Oh, come on, I already did this, please.
I don't know where that came out.
Oh, oh, please, Barry, just make it.
Oh, wait.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, why am I in here?
Is there no secret?
Okay.
Let's go.
Okay, now we're done.
Okay.
You can do it this time.
Ah!
See, it was so easy.
You should do it.
Hey, hey, hey.
Ah!
A
2013 game?
That's over 10 years old.
That's true.
2013 was 20 years ago.
22.
22 years ago.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's go spend our money.
You do first.
Okay, okay.
Whoa, I have 153.
Robo?
Oh, a leaf.
I don't know what that is.
Shark?
Ew!
Oh, wee-wee.
Oh, that's just a little guy.
Ew.
Oh.
Xamu.
Scali!
Monster!
Oh, that's it.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
That's not good.
Yeah?
Stop it.
Sorry.
Did you see what you got?
It was like a bear.
It was cute.
Oh, I like the teeth.
The puppy is so cute.
Oh, the puppy is so cute.
Otacon!
A pirate.
A shark.
Eyeball.
Robo man.
I don't know, yeah, I don't know what that is.
Oh, chef!
Oh, that's it.
I'm gonna go buy more.
Yeah, oh, this way.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
You gonna buy?
Oh, I don't...
It's not letting me buy.
I think I bought everything, maybe, that they have.
Oh, maybe.
I got snot.
Snot.
I got the golf ball.
Yeah, the really bad golf ball.
I got a fan.
Oh, collect all the weapons from the gift shop.
Oh, I got them all too!
Okay, nice!
Wait, that means we don't have to get the yarns anymore.
Yeah, oh, okay.
Yeah, I don't know if you would use the yarns for it.
What's the fan do?
I mean, it just blows you.
Ah, wait.
And then I got a snot.
Oh!
Ew, it's still going!
Oh my god, it is!
Wait, why?
Why?
There we go.
Okay.
Ah!
Toxic snot.
Oh.
Do you want to wrap up here then?
I guess so.
I guess then next time we would actually... Wait, so we stopped before at 4.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me look up how many chapters.
Let me...
theater how many chapters yeah it has eight chapters eight chapters yeah yeah so there's one more so we got through two this well four five six we got through three so we could do yeah I think we can complete it well I mean for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you for playing with me again thanks about
This was Meat and Block Kingdom.
Thank you guys so much.
Okay, next time we're lock-in for sure.
We got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys for watching.
I'm going to talk to my chat for like two seconds.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to go eat.
Otsumito.
Oh, what do you say?
Otsubiri.
Bye-bye.
Oh, bye-bye.
what what oh i mean i was just gonna say bye to the to my community yeah me too oh okay okay i'll hang up the discord oh no okay you can hang off you know oh wait no no i'll i'll i'll mute for a second i'll mute oh okay okay yeah we can talk about yeah okay okay she actually muted wait what if i don't mute hey guys oh my gosh thank you for I'm watching What the Oh,
sorry, sorry
Okay, I'm muted for real this time Thank you guys Thank you, thank you, thank you I said on Twitter I was like I think I might do another stream after this But I'm so stinkin' hungry That I am afraid I don't think I will stream again after this I'm so,
I wanted to do it Because I feel like I had so many collabs recently, and so I was like, I kind of want to just have a stream where it's not a collab, but I'm so sorry!
I'm so hungry!
I'm so, so hungry.
And yeah, this game is so much.
Oh, but that's okay.
We'll have time to talk tomorrow.
Yeah.
It's feature length.
I have another collab this week too as well, which is why I was like, oh, well, since I have this collab today.
Which was supposed to be yesterday, but that's my fault.
Since I had that today, and then another collab.
And then I had Nimi collab too, so many, many collabs recently.
So sorry.
The other collab I have this week, though, is with Moni and Mimi and Camilla.
It was supposed to be a couple weeks ago, and it had to get postponed, and so we postponed it until...
until tuesday so yes so it wasn't it's not technically a new collab it's something that was supposed to happen before actually let me look at my schedule my calendar yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so oh she got the money
looking forward to seeing you at the concert at the end of the week too oh for a yummy mama Yeah, Ayami Mama is debuting a new 3D model for her 5-year anniversary.
And I will be on there just for a little bit.
To be like...
Actually, you guys, what kind of poses do you want to see Ayami Mama do?
What do you want to see her?
What kind of pose?
Downward Dog.
No!
Oh, I'm not asking you guys anything anymore.
Pass it forward.
I'm passing it forward to Doki Bird.
Oh, the Iron Mouse concert.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah.
Busy.
So busy lately, my mind.
Yes.
The Iron Mouse concert as well.
Wait, so did I thought I, Yami Mama, maybe announced something.
But I guess I'll let you guys know that I'll just be there.
But I'm not, like, appearing in 3D or anything like she did for me.
I'm just going to be there asking her to do poses.
Guys, for the next couple of months, I'm not even kidding you.
It's like, I'm so busy up until Christmas.
After Christmas, I'm free.
Until then!
Oh!
But some things...
But things are...
Not as many things have been announced yet.
So once they're announced, then...
You'll be like, wow!
Wee!
Ginto has B-Day merch too.
Oh, that's also until the end of the month!
My birthday merch!
I should probably put that like somewhere.
I mean, do you want to raid the same person?
Oh, yeah.
I guess you're on YouTube.
Oh, I can raid YouTube person, too.
Who's on YouTube?
I know.
We raided Matara last time.
I feel like...
Did we?
Oh, my God.
We did.
She caught me a whore.
Oh, Nimi is streaming.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you want to raid Nimi Nimi?
What's wrong?
I'm shy.
But also, wait, hold on.
Let me see if I can write anyone who's Twitch only.
I'll read someone Twitch only, and then I'll also redirect my YouTube raid to Nimmy as well.
Okay.
Sorry, did I...
You can continue your wrap-up.
No, it's fine.
I was just lamenting about...
Lamenting?
Oh.
Oh, no.
No, no.
It's okay.
Don't be so busy.
I don't.
Okay, I'm gonna rain.
Mia was here earlier, so I'll raid Mia on Twitch.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
I hate the new YouTube setup.
It's so bad.
Uh-oh.
There's a new YouTube setup?
Yeah, on the back end.
Do you not see it?
Uh, it's the same for me, but maybe it's yet to update for me.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, Matara is streaming.
Do we want to raid Matara again?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
No, you can raid Nimi.
I can't raid Nimi because I don't think she has me on favorites.
Oh, then that's...
Let's raid Matara then.
Oh, okay, okay, hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
Then I'll raid Matara on Twitch as well then.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Triple Matara raid!
All right.
I'll raid Mia next time.
I'm sorry, Mia.
Okay.
Matara Matara Matara Khan Thank you for the Thank you so much for the super Tattoo guys Thank you Thank you Thank you Thank you You should give her more money Give her everything No I don't have a money Emo so that doesn't apply to me
Give her everything Give her everything Okay Okay All right Thank you everybody Thank you Bye